Wait, wait. Is she crowdfunding to kidnap Perise? Yes. I have
been over 100 times before the age of seven.
>> Yeah, on the show. I got flashbanged by that, dude.
I'm not playing the intro. I'm not playing the intro.
>> He read it. >> He read it. >> I'm not playing
the intro.
>> Play the intro, Nick. Play the Play the >> We're
just going to move past that stuff. Let's get the content.
I told you. I told you. I told you, dude. I'm sorry. It's so
over. It's never been more over. It's never been more over than
it is right now.
Hold on. This post is deleted. When was this post deleted?
When was this post deleted? And do we have archives? Cuz are
we losing our H3 mod drama to post deletions? I want to know.
Ray Mod is struggling after a breakup and has set a go set up
a GoFundMe. Uh oh. Wait, when did when did stuff getting delete?
When did stuff start getting deleted is what I want to know.
So, the H3 community manager, the the head community manager,
the mod who's been in the community for three years.
Um,
and she even used to go on she's been on the H3 podcast a few
times. Okay. Chronic oversharer. She basically goes to this community
and seems to like make up new lies when she needs to use them
like a piggy bank in some way. Okay. This seems seems to be how
it is.
All right. I We're going to have to go through like every piece
of this. I'm trying to see. So, my one sent me some
>> Let's start with the breakup thing. Okay. So, here here
this is um Ray Mod is struggling after a breakup. Check it out
here and help if you can. GoFundMe. Support my journey to stability
and safety. She also has one trying to help out her niece out
of an abusive situation. Help Francis escape a life of abuse.
Fundraiser by Sierra Rain. Support my journey to stability and
safety. 3,000 of 15,000 donated.
I have been over 100 times before the age of
Okay, I'm get Hold on. I'm getting a certain vibe here.
Wait, what? Wait, wait. I think she means since she was seven.
I think she means since she was seven. I think
I have been over a hundred times before the age of seven. The
last time being when I was 23. I think between the ages of seven
and 23. Got to be. Got to be. Got to be.
>> I have survived a driveby in one of my childhood neighborhoods.
I live with my sister in the projects where someone attempted
assault on me and my neighbor had gang affiliations and apparent
affinity for eating stray cats. Dude, how do you not just how
do you not just look at this immediately and go um oh she means
before? Okay, well that's crazy. How do you not just immediately
go, "Oh, this person's an obvious like pathological liar." Like
this is already I'm just like this is an obvious pathological
liar. Obvious clear like immediately, right?
It's already over. I'm I'm two sentences in and it's over. Three
sentences in. I did that so I so
I live with my sister in the projects, blah blah blah blah blah.
I did that so I could escape my abusive ex-husband. My parents
pulled me out of school after third grade. So I have some college
done and I'm trying to get my GED this year. I My parents pulled
me out of school after third grade. So I have some college done
and I'm trying to get my GED this year. What? I have some college
done and I'm trying to get my GED. These are out of order. How
do you have college done, but you're trying to get your GED?
She made She has this opening and she made $3,000.
Sorry. I have been
Okay. All right. I Okay. All right. We're Listen,
I like need more music or something. Hold on. I need like different
music. I somehow need better vi better vibe music. Okay. I I
don't know what is the vibe for this. What do you even do? What's
the vibe going on here?
>> Okay. Anyway, sorry. I Dude, every line every line is
like something I have to pause.
Scroll up. Someone dropped $500.
Cesar Enrique top donation.
>> this guy has paid for this girl's pictures in some way
or another. This guy is like paid to be on some private Instagram.
This guy has paid to be There's something going on here
that's sinister. Okay,
there's something very sinister going on here. I'm telling you.
Okay, sorry. Every line makes me pause. It's taken longer because
my ex-husband was a who groomed me until I finally got away.
It they just keep coming. The blows keep coming. He was a who
groomed me until I finally got away. Living in that space, I
developed an anxiety disorder on top of already having autism.
Wow. A while after that, I met who would be my partner for the
next two years until yesterday. Meeting him made me made my life
go from feeling like a horror/thriller to a romantic comedy most
of the time. We had kids names picked out and talked all the
time about getting married and our future. He comes from money
that he and especially his parents have worked very hard for.
So when we moved out to LA last year in January, we were able
to get a supremely beautiful place in such a safe and gated area.
One that I could have never dreamed of living in. I can't drive
and there's a lot of stuff to walk around here. Oh, sorry. But
there's a lot of stuff to walk around here. all the essentials
like grocery store etc.
And I've been here for a year now. I have a couple of friends
within walking distance. So I feel very confident I would be
happy staying here even on my own. I cannot afford this place
on my own at this moment and I need to resign my lease within
about a week from writing this. Re resign, not resign. Resign
your lease. I missed the context of this. Go back 2 minutes and
watch. I don't have I don't have good credit as one could probably
guess from the generational poverty and not having any guidance.
I am trying so hard to do better specifically for my niece who
is stuck in an abusive situation that's being ignored and neglected
by CPS and the police. Wait, she called CPS.
That's quite bad. Sorry. Low hanging fruit. Low hanging fruit.
I'm sorry. That's very low hanging fruit. I have another GoFundMe
posted for her so I can help her press charges should she want
to and to give her a stable place she can live with me while
I guess we both heal. The GoFundMe I I dude I don't think this
I suspect I won't actually say this is a concrete statement based
on what I've read so far.
Oh, sorry. I was going to say with her niece I do not believe
I do not believe
that this person should be taking care of someone else based
on what I've read so far. Okay. It's probably not a great
pretty obvious to most people if like this this seems very unbelievable.
I do not think this person should be taking care of somebody
else like especially her niece. Okay. The GoFundMe continues
to pay for the private investigator to get proof of the abuse.
So CPS will have to listen this time hopefully. Please if you're
wanting to donate, donate to the to that one first. First, sorry,
every donation is appreciated though. I don't want to go back
to that horror movie feeling. I am so afraid and I have no family.
Most were abusive, so I've cut them off, including my parents.
My plan would be to use this GoFundMe money to keep my apartment
while I look for a lo second local job to support myself here
in the long run.
I feel like I've had the best two years of my life and was really
starting to believe it wasn't was really starting to believe
it wasn't going to go away. I didn't I don't want to lose this
home, too. Traditionally, my bedrooms have been in public spaces
like dining rooms with a mattress on the floor or top bunk of
a moldy RV bunk bed. Sorry, this is so rambly and poorly written.
I'm on mobile, very tired, and my brain is all around just foggy.
I am so afraid. Thank you so much. Okay.
95 donations. That's immediately from this. She also has one
trying to help her niece out of an abusive situation. 62,000
raised of 70k. Okay. Uh we need to keep we need to keep reading
then. Okay. My niece has been failed by CPS,
her grandparents,
and her parents. Now, correct me if I'm wrong.
The grandparents of her niece would have to be her parents. Yes.
Am I wrong? It's your your niece as in your brother or sister's
daughter
as in that person's grandparents. Your niece's grandparents would
be your parents or your significant other's parents. I guess
if that was if it was like But if it's not blood related then
no. But hold on. But I don't know if she's even married now.
And like I don't think she'd be trying to pull her Oh, my parents.
Her grandparents. Oh, there you go. Okay. All right. CPS has
sent her back to a home with a child and abuse her. I know they
are those things because one of her parents, my sibling, is the
same that abused me beginning at age five. My parents, her grandparents
are physically and mentally abusive as well as in support of
their child to the
my parents her grandparents. Oh yes, yes, yes. Are physically
and mentally abusive as well as in support of their child to
the point of accusing me and their other victims of false memories.
Okay. as well as later admitting to it happening but saying I
should get over it. I refused to let them take advantage of my
silence anymore. I tried for years to get custody of her but
when my parents found out they contacted my sibling and they
have they have hidden her from me since then.
Resources like police and nonprofits that do wellness checks
can't help me because I don't have any solid information on her
whereabouts as they have hidden her so well. Nor do I have any
nor do I have proof of what my sibling has done to us. She is
turning. She is now 17, turning 18 in April 2026. And CPS blew
their chance so hard to be of any real use anymore. Okay. All
I want is my niece in a place where she feels she is where she
feels and is safe, whether that is with me or not. I want to
hire a private investigator to help me find a way to contact
her so I can so I can ask her where she wants to go because I
know she doesn't want to be there. She opened a CPS case against
her stepfather and to try to get out of and most recently take
or try sorry to try to get out and most recently tried to take
her life. She deserves so much better than this. No child deserves
this. I actually think this is probably something that shouldn't
even be posted
Like I I I legitimately think it's probably harmful to have these
pictures of like this kid. I honestly if I could go back and
like not include any of these pictures, I might. Um, it's it's
actually bordering on harmful if if it turns out this isn't true.
It's pretty harmful to put all of this stuff online in a way
that could be traced back to like your your niece or your like
siblings.
It's pretty not good. This might be real. Probably, but I'm still
not 100% sure.
Um, probably not. I think you mean Yeah, I'm not 100% sure either
way. I'm just saying that
there's a level of
it's not impossible,
but there's a level of unbelievability here that starts with
her own story that I'm like, I just don't know if I believe this
for her story. Yeah. So, it I mean, maybe it's not maybe it's
real, but dude, the unbelievability of this story immediately
just puts me in a place where I'm very I'm very
suspect of this entire thing so far. And that's without Listen,
a whole bunch of people looked into some other stuff here. There's
a lot of other links going on. Okay. A lot of other stuff going
on here. Okay. So, we're looking we're looking through these
two GoFundMes. This is going to get us invested. All right. With
this is where we were. With any money left over from the private
investigator, I will use it to help her escape
and get her set up for whatever she may need. Examples: clothes,
personal hygiene stuff, furniture, college. When she's ready,
if there's any leftover from these things, I want to put that
in a savings account in her name. I wish someone who who I wish
someone had tried to help me as a child. someone who didn't have
ill intent. I have been in abuse situation after abuse situation
because I did not have any real guidance until I got into therapy,
divorced my abusive ex-husband, and cut off my parents. I'm now
thriving, and I want to I want that for her, too. But I want
to skip over I want to skip all I want her to skip all the other
abuse. I want her to know she has a choice beyond taking her
own life and living up with child and abusers. Now, there's some
part of this where like I do think people who have been abused
early on in life can have a propensity to like want to escape
and are like vulnerable to being abused again. I think that's
a very real thing.
so it's it's not like that is the part that I find unbelievable
like you've been abused a lot and you have like that will open
you up. You will be vulnerable to being abused in the future.
That's not the part I find unbelievable. It's some of the just
like the the numbers that seem a little unbelievable, a little
hyperbolic. Anyway, yeah, that's that's where my hesitancy comes
from. Okay. I have been in therapy for years and medicated Prozac
for a little over a year now. I'm in a very stable point in my
life, but I'm I am still recovering from the debt it took to
get away from my abuser, which is another thing I want her to
not have to deal with. I am by no means thriving financially,
but again, I am stable. She was born when I was 9 years old,
and I was so lucky to have her in my care between the ages of
6 months to 1 year and then again from 3 years to 6 years. No
one was t taking care of the baby and eventually it came to feel
that she was my baby. She used to call me mommy when she was
a toddler and as much as I felt that too and wished it were true
or wish it were the case, I couldn't allow her to call me that
out of fear that if my sibling heard they would beat us both
or not want to care for uh her anymore again. No one would take
care of the baby besides people I knew would only harm her. I
had to be there and I'm glad I was. I would do it all again for
her in a heartbeat. Okay. 9-year-old taking care of a six-month-old.
So she was nine and so this person was 9 to 10 when she first
take care took care of her and then from 12 to 15 she also took
care of this baby. Now that is something that happens in poverty
situations where it's like a kid who's way too young ends up
taking care of like very very young kids as well, right? This
is something that does happen. That's not impossible. It's just
another thing that's like fairly unlikely and seems
hard to believe, but it is what it is. Please, if you are able
to comfortably donate, it would mean the world to me and I am
sure to her. To reiterate, with the money you all donate, I want
to hire a private investigator, say aside hopefully $5,000 to
be able to help her escape when the time comes and replace whatever
she may have lost or never had. Then finally, with whatever may
be left over, I want to put it into a savings account in her
name. Her name is Francis, and she's the best kid ever. Thank
you.
How long has this one been running for? This one has been running
for Dude, Gabriel Wright, 1,500 bucks. See all Cart Wilhelm?
I just want to see when did this start? Two days, three days.
Actually, let's go to top and just see when the So, this has
been running for two months. So, this was the first story. As
of two months ago, this was the first story. Okay.
And then after that, this comes second. Okay. This is her new
one. And I'm guessing that with this story, people start to go,
"Oh, wait.
Oh,
wait. Wait. Is she crowdfunding to kidnap her niece? Yes, that
is what that first one is. or to get a pretext. Now,
basically, not to kidnap her niece necessarily. She says, not
with not necessarily with her, just to get her out of that house.
But I do think there's like some if this person has a propensity
to overexaggerate things, there's a chance that like I I'm just
saying there is a there's another chance that a small chance
that she's overexaggerating some things. Her niece is like not
in significant danger. And she's both getting money for a private
investigator to look into this without really the support of
anyone else
and looking to move that niece out of the house without the support
of the family or the support of the niece.
I It seems pretty
yikes. Pretty sketchy. Okay. Pretty sketchy. Little concerning.
All right. How do we How do we go through this? Okay. Oh god,
no. Not again. Wait, there's more stuff. Oh boy. So this starts
one year ago is her first GoFundMe in this community. Okay. One
year ago, this is the original GoFundMe she wants to run. Okay.
Not sure if still H3 affiliated, but Ray is sure for is for sure
family.
What is she saying here?
GoFundMe to cover my nana's funeral cost. My family and I can't
afford a funeral for her. We did get a funeral for my mom, her
daughter, when I was 17 because we didn't have the money have
money then either. I don't know what else to do. And I know many
of you are also financially struggling. So there is pressure.
So is there is so pressure. I'm guessing this is no pressure
to donate. But if you can out can out would be it would be very
appreciated. She was a and a rap survivor who loved her family
so much and got her first tattoo on her 60s
uh in her 60s of a unicorn she was very proud of.
She deserves a funeral. Okay. Do skits not have auto correct?
I don't know. I wish I could better explain how amazing this
woman is. She gave me so much hope as and love as an kid. She
had the same struggles but went through them uh in a harder time
but still pulled through and lived a long and healthy life. She
didn't get to meet all her grandkids but she loved them all with
her whole heart and oh my god she was so funny. My almost sole
purpose for checking Facebook was to see the results of the most
recent Buzzfeed quiz she took. Celebrity
she looks like the most is Maunis.
I love her so much she deserved the world. Okay. Sorry for the
typos. See, there she she says, "Sorry for the typos, guys. This
is the first GoFundMe she runs for her grandmother's funeral."
Let's take a look.
Will GoFundMe load today?
Can I try this again? Hello.
I wonder if this is VPN causing issues here. Nope. This GoFundMe
link is not working. And then there's a post in here. I just
want to say thank you all so much. And again, I'm sorry for all
the typos. There's no pressure to donate, but like I said, it
means the world. I come from generational poverty and it hurt
a lot to not have a funeral for my mom. This almost feels like
a funeral for them both. Thank you guys so so so so much. Family
forever. I love you all. Oh, fundraiser not found. Uh-oh. Guys,
what happened to this fundraiser? What happened to this one?
Where'd this one go? This is a year ago. I thought her mom was
an abuser. I thought so, too. I thought her mom was an abuser
who was alive.
Apparently furthering the abuse of this kid, right? Where is
that? Here. Um, not this one, but this one. My parents, her grandparents
are physically and mentally abusive. Are physically and mentally
abusive. My parents, her grandparents. Now, maybe her dad got
remarried and
that's what's happening. She doesn't say that though. Could be
a steparent. Yeah, could be a steparent technically. Is she the
same girl who had an episode on H3 a while back? She's been on
the H3 podcast a few times, apparently. She t does talk about
her her steparents in some trauma dumping to save her niece stories.
Okay,
maybe would that be stepparents through a marriage or stepparents
like her her current partners or the partner she just broke up
with? Would it be that her their parents or I actually don't
know. Okay, we we're going to keep reading. Okay. Okay.
So, 3 months later, she mentions how it's her mom that died.
Image one, but apparently she died eight years ago as well. She
discusses that she is too low income to afford these things and
there are programs in her state of Georgia and California and
in California for people whose loved ones die that they can't
afford cremation receives a serious donation from Ethan
$2,000 as well as the rest of the community. Ethan paid for my
nana's funeral which was incredible. Was able to make into a
joint funeral for my mom cuz we could afford one back when she
passed. Couldn't afford one I'm guessing. Rifa male. Okay. Wait,
image one.
Is that image one from here? When I was 17 because we didn't
have Oh,
we didn't get a funeral. So,
this is for her mom who died when she was 17. Wait, how old is
this person now? They're 25
in the DMs.
Oh. Oh, I see. Uh, I just want to say thank you all so much.
And again, I'm sorry for all the typos. There's no pressure to
donate. Means the world. I come from generational poverty and
it hurt a lot not to give my mom a funeral. This almost feels
like a funeral for both of them. Thank you guys so so so much.
Family forever. Sorry about your mom passing away. Wait. Okay.
Yeah, she's she is 26. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Wait, but how do you think her mom passed away a year ago? Heard
a lot not to have a funeral for my mom. Here she mentions that
how her mom died. I don't have this in the DMs here where she
mentions how her mom died. Uh, hold on. I'm I'm losing track
of this a little bit here. My wand. >> I just need a little
help to get back on track here real quick. You could help on
stream if you want.
I don't see Okay, never mind. And I was just reading something.
It's not important. It's not important. This is what Oh, wait.
Wait. This one isn't that she's having a funeral for her mom.
They turned it into a joint funeral or whatever. It seems like
that's fluid. Sorry. I'm I'm reading through like your descriptions.
This is just a little off. I think it makes sense that they're
having a funeral for both of them. I think please read s reply.
Baby, sorry about your mom passing away. Baby, you [__]
uh
Wait, what? Wait, why is this a What is this? What is this?
Who is this person? It's an H3 meme. I do not get it. What a
weird meme.
Okay. Approximately six months ago, she starts talking about
Francis Bean, not Francis Bean Cobain, who is her niece, who
she thinks is definitely being abused by her parents. Video deals
with CSA discussion, but no pics of the kid. The who's abusing
this child changes to
sister's boyfriend over the following months.
Okay, hold on. There's a video we got here. My niece opened up
a CPS case against rapists who are >> Okay, I'm starting
to see where the donations are coming from. I'm starting to see
and suddenly it came to me. It hit me like a It hit me like a
train. Okay, I'm starting to see how all these donations came
through out of nowhere. Wow. Isn't that crazy? >> Opened
up a CPS case against her, who are also her parents and CPS sent
her back. She's already asked for help. She's made it clear what's
happening. CPS has failed. I started speaking out about what's
going on. I've been seeing results and like fast results. If
you want to help me help save my niece's life, you can either
donate to the GoFundMe that's linked in my bio. You can interact
with any of the posts that I have made about her, including this
one, because it spreads it further to people who can donate if
you're not able to, which is totally chill. If you have uh child
custody and domestic violence attorney referrals, that would
be fantastic. And if there are any media outlets at all that
would be >> some crazy work. Listen, what was I saying
that this is unbelievable? It's almost like I'm I'm seeing the
light. We got to save this kid. >> Comfortable letting
me tell my story. Making the chances more likely that I will
save her because I I need to can't be stuck in that. It's so
disgusting. And I know those people. They're my family, unfortunately.
>> Oh, hold on.
Hello, Private Huff. Thank you for the two gifted subs. Uh, that
puts us over for another hour on the stream. Thank you so much,
Private Huff. Thank you. Thank you. We continue. >> Last
time. >> So, all right.
She knows the abusers because they are her family. >> That
would be comfortable letting me tell my story. Making the chances
more likely that I will save her because I I need to can't be
stuck in that. It's so disgusting. Reban Ruben donated $3. That
paragraph is distracting.
>> And I know those people. They're my family, unfortunately.
And the last time they assaulted me, I was 14 and they had a
gun. She had plans for the next night. Uh men in their like 30s
to come over. Two of them would assault me. >> You went
>> Yo, Mad T, thank you for the five gifties. Let's go.
Let's go. Let's go.
I sorry I should get some text over this. My bad. So she was
14. They had a gun and then men in their 30s would come >> Two
of them would assault me. Thankfully I got I got out of there
and even then I I tried to go back to keep Francis safe. Please
help.
I cannot express to you how serious this is. My niece opened
up a CPS case. >> Okay. All right. Was the overunder on
her parents being also a part of the scheme? Well, I think she's
saying it's against the parents and then she's saying how
we're also her parents. So, it must be her brother or something
that abused her when she was younger, right? Brothers significantly
older. No, this stuff doesn't necessarily fail the track for
me. Okay. Like I I've not seen anything in this story yet that
feels impossible. Okay. Like the the idea that you're from a
very poor family. Um you were abused by like your sibling. Although,
wait, it's her parents as well, right? >> Those people.
They're my family. I know those people. They're my family. >> The
last time they assaulted.
>> So, she was 14. She's got like an older sibling who's
got to be right. When she was 14, Francis would be uh sorry,
Francis would be
So their her sibling would have a 5-year-old kid
making them, you know, probably somewhere in the 20s or early
20s, mid mid to early 20s. So like this is believable that in
a really like I don't know, like a really impoverished family,
this hillbilly family, you got some [__] like this
going on. It it certainly seems like it would be >> Me,
I was 14 and they had a gun. And she had plans for the next night.
Uh men in there like 30. She had plans for the next night. So
then is it her sister that's abusing her, right?
If we take this quite literally, that would be her sister. No,
the last time she was abused by her family was 14. The last time
she was abused was 23, right? So she moved out. She got away
from her family and then she was like better off. Okay. I'm starting
I Dude.
Oh boy. All right. So, we go from this to then basically from
this to the GoFundMe for Francis. All right. This one that's
made $62,000
so far. Uh, yeah. My wand. If I'd been working off of your stuff
early on, I would have seen you give me a warning about the pics
of the kid. That's kind of I feel bad about having that. So,
she let slip kind of early on that she hasn't seen this niece
in about 10 years. Image three. Uh-oh.
Really? I have tried for over a decade to get in contact with
her, but our family is insane and has fully cut us off from each
other. This is the last resort. This is the most recent picture
of Francis. She is 17 right now and turns 18 in April. She's
not missing. She is stuck in an abusive home that CPS has has
sent her back to and she believes she has nowhere to go or nowhere
else to go. I have a safe home for her. I just need her to know
so that she that I just need her to know that so she can make
a choice that isn't staying with abusive people or so. Hold on.
Hold on.
Tried getting
I've tried for over a decade to get in contact with her.
Just fully cut us off from each other. So she hasn't talked to
this person. How does she know that this person filed the CPS
case? How is this all out there and in the open if she hasn't
talked to the person? Dude, what? How? I'm I'm so confused. Okay,
she uses pictures from of her from when she was five in order
to milk sympathy bucks. GoFundMe started around 5K, but it's
currently sent to 70K and 89% funded. It's even higher now. To
reiterate, she does not have custody. She has never had custody.
She should not have custody and she doesn't know where the kid
is. Dude, I feel like
I feel like this is crazy. Um, there's trouble in Paradise Brewing
starting from about 3 months ago after she began doing the H3
Orbiter circuit to eBag. So, she apparently was going on people
around H3 to eBag from them.
>> This is Alex the fiction >> by giving you a by
creating a PSA. Uh Ry has been desperately looking for her niece
Francis. Uh Ray, can you tell me a little bit about this?
>> So, my niece Francis is 17, turning 18 uh in April 2026.
She is not missing. She's in in a home with child.
again. Um, you don't want to put this stuff up. I You just shouldn't
be putting this stuff up. It's stupid.
I don't know. I might flip the the VOD over to something else.
You You really shouldn't be putting this person up at >> And
um I know because I am one of the
>> The annoying thing to me here is that this Alex the
fiction guy put it up himself. Like this is his OBS where he's
gone to put this up. Are you out of your
>> of those people? They are my family. I wish they weren't
my family. >> Jesus Christ. Hold on. Oh, you're just going
to be flashing pictures of them the whole time. >> So,
I wanted to start this interview by giving you a by creating
a PSA. Uh,
>> have hidden because I am one of the victims of those
people. They are my family. I wish they weren't my family. I
wish they weren't her family, but they >> Um, years ago,
they found out that brother, you need help. Listen, we're just
trying to we're just trying to make sure we protect this person's
identity as best. >> I wanted custody of her and they have
hidden us so well that I don't have any information on like how
to locate her and resources won't help because of that. Um because
what what I'm saying is like hearsay about to them a hypothetical
person
and they're not going to you know spend a bunch of resources
their own resources looking for somebody that they can't be like
oh yeah know we know cuz I'm just some random person to them.
>> Okay.
Can I ask how does she know about the does she reveal how she
knows about the CPS case
where your eyes looking? I don't see the picture. Okay. Take
picture is over on OBS. I don't keep OBS up while I stream. So,
unfortunately, that's just for you guys. I'm just looking at
full on the PII of this supposed victim. Okay, she called CPS.
There's no way that she's the one who called CPS because I swear
to God. Oh, hold on. Well, oh, you guys are about to get wrecked.
I have to have my thing there. So, unfortunate for you guys.
I'm not going to cut her face off. You guys have lost a little
bit. >> Um,
and I just want I have I have a safe home for her. I have a home
for her where she's loved and wanted. I I can help her heal.
I can help her thrive after abuse. I want to help her get into
college when she's ready get a job um and learn what healthy
love is like. >> It's from 2 months ago, by the way. >> But
she just doesn't know that she has a choice. And because of that,
recently she tried to take her own life, which is why I've decided.
>> How does she know that? How does she know that this
person tried to
>> um
take the risk of talking about
>> Oh, Jesus Christ. Why do you keep cycling through these?
>> Um I don't want to encourage anybody to like specifically
go look for her, but because that's obviously insane, >> but
but I don't want to encourage anybody to go look for her.
But I would, the goal would be that someone who already knows
her, like an old friend or an old teacher or something,
recognizes her, sees the video from it circulating around uh
one of the videos, whatever, and they find a way to help us get
in contact. cuz I guarantee you,
I mean, I would be surprised if
people know about what's going on with her outside of CPS and
um they should just be so ashamed of how how horribly
>> So, the signals we have so far are that she called CPS
and CPS didn't do anything,
that CPS investigated and didn't find that this child is abused,
Like I guess in in at these times, don't you just you run like
both sides of it? Like if the if the kid isn't getting abused
is obviously very bad. Ethan has to totally denounce this, right?
Calling CPS on a totally normal family.
Dude,
then somebody man,
there's some cosmic force that just makes things like this happen.
like coincidental things come about like this that are
like what do you is this just is this literally serendipity that
like
it happens to be that this person
appears
it's at least possible she's essentially calling CPS is doing
the same thing that happened to Ethan to her former family sorry
to her the family she used to be in contact with
Nope scripted Truman show it feels like that a little bit feels
very weird to me dude Dude, this is why >> they have failed
her. It's disgusting. But yeah, she is a she's a sweet and beautiful
and wonderful kid. She's she's so funny and full of life and
uh man, I have I have her hat uh still from when she was a toddler.
>> Oh wow. So yeah, throughout your >> There's the
picture flashing up on the stream of the the kid wearing the
hat >> showing images on screen and uh if someone does
have information, how do they go about contacting you? I am on
Instagram. I'm on Discord. I'm on
>> Dude, dude. Dude, I'm sorry.
Uh,
people really are that people really just are that gullible,
I guess.
Yo.
>> Really? Any socials? Um, under the username Rafel. R
A E P H E M E L. Um,
just DM me. I'm I'm looking for messages. So, so
>> now hold on. I would say that people are
totally throwing this person under the bus. Like they're like
they're totally grifting here. I don't know if I believe that
either. There is a chance that they like I I would say there's
a decent chance that they're genuinely having like a like some
kind of moment here where they think this is true. Not, it's
not even provably false yet, but like
I don't know how much I'd weigh this to like her grifting versus
her genuinely believing this is true. And like probably people
need to go and tell her like, "Hey, people need to like check
on her first and make sure she's doing okay." Even Dioro couldn't
sweep for this today. Yeah. No, no doubt. I'm saying that like
for me it feels like when I see this when I see somebody who's
in like a community like this and they're farming something out
like this in a totally disingenuous way, right?
Like in a way that's obviously going to come back to bite them.
They're like burning a whole bunch of connections. You don't
really do that if you like
she could have stably farmed this community pretty easily. So
I feel like there could be something going on here where we don't
know like is this person okay? Is this person stable? I don't
know if they can really make these allegations. I don't know
if they're thinking straight.
She has been to be fair. >> I'm I'm gonna set up an email
soon, which will probably
be RAML at Gmail or something um so that people can send stuff
more officially. Uh
cuz yeah, I I want to give it my best >> I'll add all that
information in the description. Do you think your niece is in
a shelter valley type of situation where she's like in a completely
secluded area with like 300 people?
>> I think probably cuz I also I know that her mom is her
mom my sister uh not the cool one obviously. Um
she is such she's an odd person.
Uh,
she's one of those like um you can't paint your nails in the
same house the baby's in because the baby will get infected by
the fumes kind of people, which is
but um on top of that, she's
insane and evil for a billion other reasons. So um >> she
just say she just say you can't paint your nails around a dude
and that's like why they're evil.
I think. Yeah, that's like pretty low on the on the list of things
so far. >> She's the Hold on. I got to listen to that again.
Sorry. I'm trying to piece together the cool obviously. Um >> I'm
trying to
So, it's her sister. Okay. I'm trying to also catch up to the
story in another way. All right. There are another million reasons.
There are >> I think probably cuz I also know that her
mom is her mom, my sister. Uh not the cool one obviously.
she is such she's an odd person.
Uh
she's one of those like um you can't paint your nails in the
same house the baby's in because the baby will get infected by
the fumes kind of >> in the same house the baby's in. So
like neurotic about her child's health.
which is
but um on top of that she's [__] insane and evil
for a billion other reasons. So, um, she's, yeah, she point is
she's like very natural nature core, and I have I have no doubt
that she's probably put them somewhere sketchy because one of
the places that I have a slight idea that they might be on
>> It's it's some far out place in the middle of a desert,
which is almost exactly like the Shelter Valley
So, I guarantee she's not in school cuz I know she was in school.
Then she was having issues with school. Um, >> hold on.
I'm going to read this. Um, there's a there's text on this. This
is the last time I saw Francis. There's an image on the left
side which is a video of this person. Um, this is the last time
I saw Francis in 2019 when she was 11 and I was 20. She and my
dad stayed over for I think a week or so. Per her request, we
made slime, drew a short comic, went swimming, and to Belmont
Park. She's such a good kid >> cuz she's getting abused.
So, it's like of course she's going to act out and have problems.
But yeah, uh I know that she she got suspended a couple times
and stuff like that and then they stopped updating me. >> That
totally cuts against Hold on. This video now totally cuts against
the fact that she said she hadn't seen her in a decade. I hadn't
seen her in a decade. And then here's a video from 6 years ago
where she sees the girl and it's a video of the girl like playing
with stuff on the floor. So, that's totally
huge discrepancy there. Um, very odd. Very >> She got suspended
a couple times and stuff like that. >> I would like to
have this stuff up on screen for you guys. It just feels irresponsible.
Like, so far what I've shown, I feel like I could just tell if
like someone was going to clip this or if somebody was going
to put it on YouTube like Riyle or something. I could just be
like, "Here's where you have to censor stuff." I think it's just
much easier if I keep this all censored out. It's like all videos
of the the >> and then they stopped updating me cuz I was
uh
they know about my plan. >> Very good. Right. Thank you
so much for sharing. And again, if any stuff like that and then
they stopped updating me cuz I was uh
they know about my plan.
>> They stopped. Sorry
>> Cuz she's getting abused. So it's like of course she's
going to act out and have problems.
Um,
but yeah, uh, I know that she she got suspended a couple times
and stuff like that and then they stopped updating me cuz I was
uh, >> okay, so she got sus. So I'm guessing the acting
out is what leads her to believe something crazy is happening.
So here's a picture right here and yes, this is literally from
her story where she says, "I tried for over a decade to get in
contact with her, but our family is insane and has fully cut
us off from each other. This is a last resort." So yeah, I'm
guessing that man I'm guessing that this is something that the
family there's like two options here, right? Either she is not
two options even. It's sort of on a continuum which is weird
to talk about where like it's possible, you know, something happened.
She was kind of abused in a way that they can't deal with and
she's turned that into like a bit of a conspiracy where the whole
family was like facilitating her abuse and now she hears about
her niece acting out and her niece is suddenly being abused in
her head. like so she acted out and now she hears about her niece
acting out and so she's filled in the gaps with what she feels
happened to her. Do you know what I mean? But I'm guessing there
probably there could easily be somewhere where she was abused
as a kid. Maybe not in a persistent way, maybe not in a systematic
way she's described, but she sort of built the idea of that conspiracy
in her head and she's sort of mapping it on to this stuff as
well. Yeah. Anyway, this was the part where she said the literal
decade thing. >> They know about my plan. >> Very
good. Right. Thank you so much for sharing and again if anyone
has any information please uh please DM Ray immediately.
All right and uh we'll jump into the interview right now.
Hello everyone. Welcome back to another episode of H3. Today
I'm with the H community's favorite.
>> Okay, so it looks like I'm scanning. I don't see him
throwing out any of the other random Wait, what? Wait, this is
just a totally unrelated interview now.
Oh, we've got some good sections here. Deserted Island with Hassan
[__] What?
We've got some good sections of this. What the? But I can move
the the picture. Okay, I can move the picture now. Looks like
we don't get any more pictures of the little kid in this part.
>> Moderator Ray. Ray, would you like >> I'll I'll
skip through a couple of these real quick. We'll watch a couple
just for flavor. Okay. Oh, deserted island with Hassan [__]
Idubbbz, or Jake. >> Deserted Island with Hassan [__]
Idubbbz, or Jake Doolittle. >> Oh, no. This is this is
a a very tough question. Um,
oh god, cuz like Hassan genuinely a little bit nervous of,
>> Um, Jake Doolittle just seems I feel like he would be
so annoying, which is like, but he would be. And then I >> Yeah,
this is literally like an H3 orbiter who interviews people about
the H3 podcast universe and stuff. >> Hey, dubs. I feel
I'll go with Jake. >> Hassan, I'm just a little Hassan
is very rapist coded. All right, very good. Good choice. I think
he'd be the most nutritious out of the three, too, if we had
if we had to eat one of them. So, I like to go with Dittle on
this question as well. >> Yeah, it's a good question. >> All
right, next question. Kind of similar. Who would you rather have
dinner with, Rich Lux, Bolex, or Cousin >> Oh, Ray, what's
the hardest part about being a mod for H3? >> It's a it's
such a um like genuinely it is a it is a very a very privileged
position to be in.
But yeah, the the the the predators and stuff like but at the
same time
>> Wait, what? Wait, what?
Uh, hold on.
There a lot of predators in the H3 community. Interesting. What's
the hardest part about being an H3 mod? Uh, there's a lot of
lot of weird creepy predators around. >> Uh, but yeah,
the the the the predators and stuff like but at the same time,
I am so happy that I can help with that because the reality is
that that stuff exists. And again, like the whole pretending
that it doesn't
it doesn't mean that you're you're safer. Like how some countries
they say that they have a like near zero
thing in their country.
>> This person thinks about a lot. We've skipped around
in this f a lot. They listen rap is top of mind at all times.
Okay. I'm just has this person considered a career as a commentator.
Okay. In the commentary community, they seem to have what it
takes. Top of mind at all times. country and then you actually
you talk to people like women there especially and they're like
oh yeah no it's horrible and they just never listen or note it
down or care. Um and then you you hear about places like Sweden
that say that they have high rate rates and it's like they do
but part of that's also that like they're they're saying it they're
warning you and they're telling you and they're making a difference
through that versus just pretending it doesn't exist. Um so yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Kind of like that. I don't know. Anyway, >> so
you would say the hardest part is having to deal with that like
mentally all the all the kind of that that you have to see >> or
is there like an actual difficult trying to like narrow down
who's doing what exactly?
>> No, those are the cuz even those are just kind of like
uh even when I'm doing that I'm very grateful for my job. So
I can't say that's the hardest part. Um but yeah. Yeah, definitely
dealing with um like sometimes you're just looking through like
what the evidence is and it's it's just evidence is like uh the
screenshots that somebody has or whatever and um or even just
the statement sometimes it it hurts but
yeah got to help people. >> Gotcha. Very good. We all appreciate
all the work you do for the community, Ray.
okay,
best section coming up. Okay, Ray's snark harassment.
Oh boy, Rey is about to be totally snarked. I need two seconds.
I'll be right back. >> Next question. Uh, as a moderator,
uh, I know you even though the moderators probably get a ton
of [__] probably even more than the crew sometimes,
I think. And I feel like a Avery is big, pretty much a lightning
rod for most of the of the Snark Kate. But what does your harassment
look like? H, how much do you get?
Um, I mostly get people me, which is funny like and they'll do
it in a like
someone said that I a couple people have said that I use H3 to
promote my Only Fans. I don't have an Only Fans. I've never talked
about having an Only Fans except in like a joking form. Um, which
is no hate to Only Fans. It's just I'm not doing it. Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. There's a Hold
on. Yeah, there. Hold on. There's a part that goes with that.
Okay. In her Wait, I'm going to cut to this. Okay. In her whole
like thing where she's trying to go through Wait, do you guys
want to Should I wait to bring that up? Cuz there is something
that comes up later.
Okay. when she's trying to show for her own where she's trying
to show for her own gofundme. Okay.
Where she actually is sort of consistently dropping that she
doesn't have money and she needs to stay where she is. So I am
so for real. It might be Only Fans this time. Okay. It might
be I might have to start an Only Fans, guys. If I can't get through
this GoFundMe
>> H3 with an O in between. >> H3 with a note in
between. Wait, what? with an O in between. Oh, damn.
You said cheek pics. Sell cheekpicks to get quick money and get
my place, then get a second local job. Not ideal, but I don't
want to feel like I'm in a horror movie again. And I feel so
safe here. I can see myself being happy here. Get yourself some
cheek pics, I guess.
Wow.
Wow. So, I do think Hold on. Stop saying terrible business sense.
Yes, this is
this is basically what I'm seeing here is there's this subtle
thing like I don't want to do work, but I might be forced to
if you don't donate. I may have to I may be forced to expose
myself if you don't donate and help me stay here, which is like
a little crazy to throw that on other people, I think. Okay,
you could work at 7-Eleven.
That's a possibility.
That's a little possibility here. Okay. 7-Eleven's always hiring.
Ian's been hired like three different times. Hired. Fired. Hired.
Fired. Hired. Fired. Anyone can get in. Why are you making me
do work, guys? There's a little There's just an undercurrent
of that. Okay.
You're getting gifted 60k. That all goes to her niece who she
hasn't seen in 10 years or 5 years. My wand or 6 years, 7 years,
10 years. That goes all to the niece, obviously. Okay. What else
do we need here? Sorry, I did want to throw that in. just she
doesn't have it only fans guys yet.
So, I need you all to understand, we all understand what has
to be done, right? You cannot donate to her GoFundMe. Okay? Nobody
donate. Nobody donate. Nobody Nobody donate.
Hold back. Hold hold the donations.
HOLD THE HOLD.
DUDE,
I'm sorry. That's up. I shouldn't say that. That's really up.
Um, okay.
Dude, I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Sorry, that was inappropriate. That
was really
Um, there's some other stuff like her posting that she was looking
for like niche Japanese-on-only cartridges for her Nintendo DS
and on eBay maybe. Let me see.
>> let's Oh, yeah. You're using them for your your Only
Fans. Um, I get I get a lot of like yourself.
And then there was one person who was like, uh, someone who was
like, "How do I unfollow this Zionist white bitch?" And I was
like, "Oh, oh, why are you I mean, I'm not a Zionist, to be clear."
Uh,
>> maybe they're maybe they're actually asking for help.
Like, I don't I can't find the >> Does this [__]
even want money? Stop saying stupid. If you need money, don't
say you're not a Zionist. Are do you even want any money? What
are you trying to do here,
>> Yeah, exactly. I'm like, I don't think messaging me
will help that. I think that'll actually make me keep popping
up for you, but whatever. Okay. >> All right. Well, that's
some like so disgusting just because you're a woman only fans.
I see that a lot, too. Um there's this person, one of my favorite
live streamers. Um her name's uh Kayla Cauldron. Uh she's someone
I had on my show recently. And just cuz she's a girl, everyone
that like on the stream asks, "Hey, so what are you selling here?
What you what's going on?" Like, bro, come on. Yeah, the amount
of I I get some weird messages
>> and it's cuz she's a girl. Everyone like on the stream
asks, "Hey, so what are you selling here? What you what's going
on?" Like, bro, come on. >> Yeah. Yeah, the amount of I
I get some weird messages
uh some weird like horny dude messages on Instagram where it's
>> uh god, I'm trying to remember what the weirdest one
was, but there was something that was like uh I love you goth
mommy something something and I was like
now I recognize Hold on. I saw
in some Discord channel last night I definitely saw a tipster
I saw a tipster photoshop. Hold on. Where was it? Somebody somebody
find me this tipster photoshop now. Was it a photoshop? It was
a photoshop, right? Please tell me it was a It was definitely
a photoshop. Come on. Come
Somebody send me some tipster. There was some tipster meme that
I saw. Is it dude? There's I feel like there was a tipster like
tipster rating this person. >> Oh, that was Did Tipster
do a goth mommy tier list before? There's no way he threw this
person. Wait, hold on. Do we know for a fact that it wasn't Tipster
who messaged her? Do we know for a fact that it was not Tipster
himself who messaged her? >> Probably my alt. My bad.
>> That's okay. That's okay. It was an
>> Fantastic. Thank you very much. >> Yeah, there
was um a couple of them like that. And then there was one uh
mostly just them being like, "How much for feet picks?" And I
just don't answer cuz a million dollars and I know you ain't
got >> Oh, maybe she was uh putting on a strong face here.
Okay. Turns out not a million dollars. What's the GoFundMe for?
The GoFundMe is for not that one. This one. What? 5K or something.
15K. 3K out of 5K. Okay. She doesn't make it through this GoFundMe.
Then she's really going to have to go to F this time, GUYS. THIS
TIME I will have to go to OF. All right. I wouldn't ever go to
OF. I just want to put it in perspective for you guys. Okay.
She will go to Only Fans to stay in her apartment, but she wouldn't
go to Only Fans to save her niece. So, who's really the bad person
here? Okay,
she wouldn't even sell a couple cheek picss to save her niece
who is being abused. Okay,
that's crazy. She had the means.
She She had the means of production to herself and she wouldn't
even sell couple of stomper pics to save her niece. Holy sh has
this been paid out? I don't know if this has been paid out. I
don't think it's been paid out. This is the real trolley problem
and she failed. I don't think she wants to do Only Fans. Just
to be clear, I think she kind of used it as a sort of a cudgle
>> Maybe one day. I don't Who who knows, Ray? Who knows?
>> Wait, I destroyed Loader Box in heated debate. Wait,
Loader Box was on this. I think Taylor could easily just like
manipulate. I'm not watching that. >> Yeah, hit me up if
you do. Show >> a numbers game.
>> Yeah, everybody has a number. >> Oh, yeah. So,
I was when you used to do live streaming, you mentioned that
you're content with your position at HU right now, but you'd
love to be more on camera. Have you expressed these feelings
with uh anyone from H3? >> Yeah. Um, I haven't talked to
them
like I haven't I haven't brought it up directly, but I've told
them that if they need any help ever, I'm always down. And then
I go into the studio on most Fridays if I >> All right,
that's true. Yeah, we we have seen a lot more of you. So, awesome.
You are getting what you wanted. So that's very good to know.
>> Yeah, it's awesome. It says
>> No, there's literally a tipster section coming up. >> It's
such an honor. They're so sweet and they bring the dogs on Fridays
especially. It's so fun.
>> That's great. Yeah.
>> Wait, so she literally goes into the H3 studio to be
a mod? Really? >> When I was in the studio, I was playing
with the dogs like crazy. They were so >> Yeah. Oh my god.
I think she just got on.
I know she's Yeah, I was in on a >> Yeah. That would have
so crazy. >> Yeah, she goes in. Yeah, she goes in to work
there >> to run into you. That would have been super cool.
>> Yeah, that would have been sick. Uh, if you're ever
there on a Friday,
>> I wish I really would want to go back. Oh, um, speaking
of your live streams, where where's the live streams at? I had
so much fun with the the first
>> Did my whole monitor just [__] up? No,
I have like a purple tinge to this text. Do you guys see that?
That this text is like purplish.
The
what's going on there? And this is all white. I don't even know
how do you do this. What the
This text to me looks completely different from this text. Looks
a bit pink. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Most difficult time being
a mod for H3. Did Rayban my post? Tster the tipster x-ray aesthetics
tier list. Hold on. Something about being goth. And then this
aesthetics tier list. Is there a lot? Is there a lot of other
cool [__] here? And what was really funny was you
would play the game for 5 minutes and you would talk to the chat
for 30 minutes and like dude this is like this is like peak uh
like community interaction right here. That was so fun.
>> Thank you. I need to get back to it. I >> Okay,
hold on. >> Oh yeah. So this was totally random, but I
really like your choice in the aesthetic. I think it's super
cool to like express yourself as goth as a former goth myself.
So tell me about that. Like what was your >> dude? Wait,
I need to see this guy. Where the where the goth picks at? This
guy was a goth.
This guy was a
>> journey to picking your your aesthetic that we see before
before us today. Oh man, I I remember being uh a little kid and
my parents at one point and they did so much, but at one point
they owned a skate shop and uh my older brother who was like
a 12 13 at the time, he was super emo running around with his
like all ripped up jeans and his his like skull shirts and stuff
like that and all his friends had that too. And I just remember
being like they're really cool. So uh we also cuz my parents
owned the skate shop. It was like easy to get free shirts. So,
I got a lot of skate.
>> Wait, her parents owned a skate shop, but she came from
generational poverty. Wait, what?
Wait, what? Wait,
whoa, whoa, whoa. What? Excuse me, dude. What? Wait, hold on.
You don't know this the brother? I I think the idea is it was
possibly the sister >> shirts, which tend to be more punk
emo. Um, but I just remember I was like, "This feels right."
And then when I was like 12, 13, it became a big thing of trying
really hard to be emo. I can send you a picture. Oh my god. Of
It's a >> Please don't send us a picture of you being 12
or 13. >> A couple really bad pictures from that era. Um,
so funny though. >> Of who? Of you. >> Yeah. Of me.
Of little 13-year-old me with some face paint on. I It's is so
>> dude. What? Here's him following a makeup tutorial.
Wait, what?
Dude, dude, so many things going on. Hold on.
>> They're doing an Dude,
what is this community? What is this community? What's going
on with this community? Oh, Ray's there. Wait, Ray's there for
this. Apparently, she was here. She not turned on her. There
she is. Oh, different Ray. >> I've been to three rituals.
The last one I went to. >> Looking so weird. Okay. All
right.
This is a very interesting community. Wait, hold on. Do we have
Nicholas on that show at all? >> Hold on. Hold on. Alex
the fiction Dioro. Wait. Where's this guy's channel? I don't
see this guy's channel.
Did that dog.
Where is this? Alex the fiction. I can actually just go back
to the video. Show >> What is up everybody
here? And today
Nope. They never have Nichol They've never had Nicholas on. Damn.
Okay. All >> And then another one of me doing Naruto jutsu
hand poses. >> But if you want to share them, I think that'd
be really fun. >> Yeah, absolutely,
Excuse me,
dude. I do want Yeah, send me those pictures of your 13. You
did white face paint. You were like a goth 13-year-old. Send
me those pictures. That'd be really,
really fun.
>> I don't Oh, I think you've probably seen my emails.
Uh cuz I think Jerel when we we did Jeopardy post put pictures
of everyone, but I'll send them to you just so you can see for
for for yourself. >> Yeah, thank you. >> Yeah. Um
so with that being said, um the activity we're going to be doing
is very aesthetics related and uh we're going to be doing a tier
list of different aesthetics. I put I went into chat GPT and
I asked it to generate different versions of you in and different
flavors of aesthetics. So we'll be ranking them on a tier. >> All
right, Ray, this is the aesthetics tier list. Uh I was very Dude,
what did he do to Tipster?
What did he do to Tipster? Tippy, no.
>> Be fascinated by your choice of aesthetic cuz I love
the Gothic aesthetic. But I was curious, what other aesthetics
could we work with here? And um you might be
dude
curious why Tipster's here. A little backstory. I had been trying
to interview Tipster for months. We've been messaging back and
forth and he ultimately declined. But I had already set up this
tier list for him and he is very interested in aesthetics too
and and um so I was curious what he would look like and this
is this is the activity I wanted to do with him and I'm like
I don't want to let this go to waste. Why not do it like a double
feature here a Ray and tipster aesthetics tier list. So here
we have uh the default uh Ray and Tipster. How would you describe
what your aesthetic
Um um a little bit of a little bit of goth. A little bit of 2012
scene.
>> Very good. Very good.
>> Okay. All right. I don't know. Do we need Is there more
of this we need? I'm trying to think. Is there more of this we
need right now? I There's I don't know how much there more there
is to this to be honest with you. I'm still looking around. Okay,
let's see. Okay, there's still other stuff. There's a streamable.
Hold on. I need to take this streamable and go to it real quick.
I need to go to this off stream because there's apparently a
pick of the kid. I just want to see >> that I have a GoFundMe
up for my caused by Cohen. But
really, really love to see that I have a gofund me by my sibling.
Now I have good time
for myself as well. Um
may have seen >> Okay, hold on. I'll listen to it and then
I'll play it after she takes the >> I have a GoFundMe up
for my niece to help get her out of a really abusive situation
involving >> involving Oh, wait. Hold on. >> Situation
involving >> caused by her parents, my sibling. Um, I unfortunately
now have one for myself as well. Gives me good time to find a
second job. Uh, hers is way more important,
which is why uh the link to donate to help my niece is in my
bio. Um, sorry, the camera is really shaky. I got this guy throwing
butt at me. My partner left me. It's very
amicable
and no hate toward them, but uh I can't afford to live in this
place cuz I have a I have a part-time job right now. Um but what
I make at the moment is not it's still about $350 under just
rent. And um I've never been in a safe place before. I feel so
incredibly safe here.
And I'm so scared of that going away. I didn't think it.
>> Oh, dude. This is rough. This is rough. This is really,
really,
really rough. Is I'll be real based on this video existing,
I am very, very shocked that this has only made $3,000. Okay.
I'm incredibly shocked that it's only made 3K. I feel like everybody
when I made my joke back here about holding the line,
I feel like everybody in the H3 audience understood that intuitively.
Now, as soon as she made these posts, okay, wait, wait, wait.
Which posts? These posts. As soon as she said this, like, I'm
going to have to move out or I'm going to have to start Only
Fans. As soon as she made these posts, she was cooked. Literally,
they all just intuitively as a hive mind went hold
the line, boys. We can hold out. We can hold. We can hold out.
Rents is supposed to be less than three 100% income as a general
rule, but she feels safe right there. She feels very safe.
Okay, back to this room. >> Not going to, but it is. That's
okay. I would really, really love to keep my home. It's uh not
very safe for me in Georgia
uh where I'm from. And I'm trying to I still want to help my
niece and give her a place to be. Um to like where I'm at right
now is a one-bedroom apartment. I give her the bedroom
when I get when when I can get her. If you want to donate to
help me find stability,
the link for that is on my >> I do think I think probably
at this point you have to be thinking your niece shouldn't be
with you if you're not in a stable place, right? Uh, you can
also PayPal me
at CC605
or um cash at me at >> Never mind. I know exactly why um
this GoFundMe is not getting funded. Never mind. They're just
going direct. They're just going direct.
They're just they're just going direct.
>> Yeah. Um
>> establish a direct private line of communication before
providing money is I think what what they're thinking. All right.
Now I need to go shower because I smell really bad and I want
to wash off all the sad. So thank you. Bye.
>> Thank you. Bye.
Okay, that was her introducing her personal sub or sorry her
personal. All right, people are like, "Oh my god, you can go
to GoFundMe over here." I noticed she didn't say it in the video.
She she must not have wanted to put that on camera. I have been
over a hundred times before the age of seven is how this opens
up. Okay, which immediate flag. Okay, immediate flag. 100 times
before seven. Something of a prodigy in this field. Very disgusting.
Very awful. Very terrible. We don't really joke about it. We
don't laugh at that. Okay. Except that it obviously it feels
exaggerated. Possibly not. Possibly not. But there are a lot
of details here that don't add up. This person is not telling
a consistent story. Very concerning. Somebody said that Nicholas
covered this stuff tonight. What did Nicholas have to say on
this? Did we get a Nicholas response to any of this stuff? Okay,
hold on.
Now, we can go to a little bit more to the Reddit thread and
we can look at some of the the Reddit posts here. Okay, give
me just a second. We've got some Reddit posts on this stuff.
All right, show her some love guys is one of them. Show her some
love guys. So, this is her with the whole I'm single again.
I like just bought him a custom clear Nintendo DS and Pokemon
Emerald for Christmas because he wanted mentioned wanting the
ladder over two years ago. It's not going to be here till Valentine's
Day. Lauo, when were we when we were supposed to go on a family
trip with his family? No hate to Ben. He's a good egg. It just
do be what it do be. I will have a Nintendo and Pokemon Emerald
soon though. That's cool.
2026 is off to a start. Bra, we were looking for houses to be
in an area that would make him happier, be closer to his family,
and more room for my niece. I asked him the night before all
of this if he wanted to marry me like we'd been asking each other
for a year plus. And he said yes, like he always did. He broke
up with me in an airport with his parents and little brother
feet away. I don't know, dog. I can't sleep. And I am worried
about where I'm going to be living. This is the safest I have
ever felt and been in my life. I love where I'm at. I would give
anything to stay. I want to throw up. Lol.
I am so for real. It might be only fans this time. I'm so scared
to leave my house and I need to resign my or sorry, resign. That
is resign, by the way. It's not resign.
That is resign my lease. Not what she meant. Re-sign.
That's how you say resign. Otherwise, you're resigning.
Not the same. In about a week. My rent is more than what I make
right now on my own. Uh, sell cheek pics to get money and keep
my place, then get a second local job. Not ideal, but I don't
want to feel like I'm in a horror movie again. And I feel so
safe here. I can see myself being happy here.
Okay. I was going to make a separate post about this, but this
seems like a good place. Ray has gotten plenty of plenty of love
from the community already in the amount of $70,000. She started
a GoFundMe on the pretense of saving her niece, who will be an
adult in April, from an apparently abusive situation. This niece
will be a legal adult in April, and no updates have been provided
regarding retaining a lawyer or a private investigator, let alone
setting up a trust in her name. That GoFundMe was started in
the beginning of November. The goal was raised the goal was raised
13 separate times from 4.5K to now 70K. That is above and beyond
what is necessary to accomplish her goals and in my opinion comes
across as trying to cash a blank check from our community. Furthermore,
within the GoFund that GoFundMe reads, "I am in a very stable
at a very stable point in a very stable point in life, and I'm
still recovering from the debt it took to get away from my abuser,
which is another thing I want her not to have to deal with."
So, is the GoFundMe for her niece, who will be a legal adult
within the time it would take to save her, or is this her uh
is this the GoFundMe for her personal debts? I personally feel
like emotional strings are being pulled to finance her situation
out of the pockets of the community. The original GoFundMe has
pictures of her niece from when she was little, which she misconr
the fact that she is 17 going on 18. Oh. Uh, which
the fact that's true. Now, she started another GoFundMe for 15K
while she gets paid to be a mod. Is there no receipts to prove
that she hasn't pocketed the money from the original GoFundMe?
Then I think this community has been exploited for self- gain.
Prove me wrong, Ray. Don't just delete this comment. Also, while
you're here, please explain to us why you deserve another 15K
without referring to past trauma. Oof.
Oof. Oof. Oof. Oof. Oof. Oof. Oof. So, hold on. Now, I'm looking
cuz we've got a couple of the posts. Okay. Oh, snarkers are looking
at this point. Apparently, there's some snark posts about this
already once we get to here. Ray's response.
Oh,
she does a big response. So, is this a Keel situation? I think
is the general theory people are going with now. Is this a capital
situation? Did she pull all of this money in and then spend all
of it? Why was she buying like an expensive gift? She was importing
from from Japan for her boyfriend and then she's like also trying
to save all this money. She doesn't have very much money. I don't
know, man. I don't know. I don't know.
Stuff's starting to seem a little weird. Tried for years to get
custody of her, but when my parents found out, they contacted
my sibling and they have hidden her from me since then. Okay.
All right. I think this post the sorry the previous post we're
looking at this is a big one. Apparently she does a response.
So this would be the response. Okay. Other random from the GoFundMe
refuses the ability to see the niece by the parents for some
strange reason. Okay. I'm still looking. I'm just looking for
there's definitely more stuff here that we're going to cover.
But oh um going back to there's just some other talking points
for like some of the previous stuff. So where her parents were,
which is she says she's from Georgia. In Georgia, if someone
dies and no one can afford the funeral, the county, not the city,
is legally responsible for providing a burial or cremation. This
assistance is available for low-income or indigent family individuals
and families who are unable to pay for funeral expenses. And
eligibility is determined by the county where the death occurred.
So, they could have like a burial for these people. They could
have get them cremated or whatever
by the
right? Uh she talks about how she wanted a funeral for her grandma
because her mom never had one, implying her mom is dead. However,
in the niece GoFundMe, she talks about her parents in the present
tense and how they're abusive to her niece. So, this would be
is this step parents or what's going on there? Right.
Wait, did she include her boyfriend in this? Oh, Jesus, dude.
Wait, wait.
This is November. Okay, this is November.
Dude, I wonder I wonder if there's something to do with the GoFundMe,
which is why the boyfriend left. You know what I'm saying?
Like I wonder if the boyfriend is literally leaving because of
something to do with the GoFundMe. Uh
it's weird. >> Have money for her escape when the time
comes because I know from experience how expensive that can be.
And with any money left over, I want to open a savings account
in her name so that she has a safety net. Obviously have my preference.
But no matter where she >> dude, what is she wearing under
this? I'm sorry. I hate to be the gooner here. wants to go is
okay as long as she is safe. As long as she feels safe and
>> Well, I'm saying you sorry. You can wear something like
this. You just don't usually wear something that's an open top
like on top of that >> is safe. I just want to help her
get there. Uh, as of making this video, I don't think any family
members have donated to help, but over 200 of y'all have, and
that's really amazing. It feels like y'all are kind of found
family in a way. It's a is a weird mix of emotions, right? Cuz
on one hand, it's like you don't want to have to be doing any
of this at all, but on the other hand, it's like, wow, what a
beautiful community of people who have come together to help
the most wonderful >> I bet they have >> child in
the world. The overall goal for the GoFundMe is $15,000. Currently,
it's at like 5,500.
>> Dude, that would be after she upped it from 5,000. The
current goal is $15,000.
Uh, looks like we've Okay, please don't. No, stop.
>> they've got nothing but pictures up here. I do not like
it. Machica, thank you for the gifted sub. >> So, they
got it up to 70,000. They got it up to 70k
$100, which is incredible and amazing because it's at $5,500.
I am now looking for private investigators, which is incredible.
I've reached out to a couple.
>> Okay, she's reached out to a couple. So, she she should
be able to provide receipts in that. >> One fell through
already, but you know, we keep we keep hustling. We keep going.
when I do find a private investigator. >> Oh, wait. Hold
on. No, no, no. I Does she understand? If one falls through,
you could just stop looking entirely. You don't ever have to
pay another one. You tried. That's all you got to do. Try one
time and then you get to keep >> I will keep you guys as
updated as much as possible because I really, really, really
appreciate what y'all have done and what y'all are doing. But
again, this this is not a this is not a done fight. It does not
begin and end at the private investigator. It is this is just
the beginning. If you want to help contribute to keeping Francis
safe and helping her live a normal, healthy, happy life that's
not filled with child,
that would be awesome. Please, please, please uh you can interact
with any of these posts or you can donate to the GoFundMe link
in my bio. Thank you guys so much. You are wonderful people and
I am forever grateful towards >> all of you. As a super
big thank you, I would like to offer you a picture of my >> That
is what they're all angling for is a picture of your cat. about
her.
Thank you so much.
>> I'm raising money. >> Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow.
Uh Ry, the other Instagram thing you sent me is literally Mike
Tomlin. So if there's a different thing for for the Instagram,
this reel, this is Mike Tomlin. You sent me a black coach just
yapping it up. Okay. So, whatever real was supposed to be there,
I would like to see it. But god damn. Okay. Are we back to reading
Reddit comments? cuz apparently she does respond to some of the
crazy [__] going on. Wholesome Ethan L. So Ethan
paid for her.
All right, Ethan did pay for her. Looking to see if I'm just
if I'm missing anything. Struggling after a breakup. Going to
leave this here. There's something sketchy about all of this.
Yeah. Okay. This is the one with peace and love. I really feel
for her situation, but I agree. I feel like she's safe from uh
safe where she's at and likes her place, but she needs to move
somewhere within her means and not ask the audience to fund her
nice living arrangement in a gated community. She's raised so
much money already in general and is talking about buying her
boyfriend expensive gifts. I'll send her some love, but we are
all struggling in this economy. And she's raised a lot of money
seeming with to seemingly no resolve. No updates, just fraud
in my opinion. But she has yet to she has yet to produce receipts
despite commenting
Listen, I never donated cuz I don't usually go in for random
people's GoFundMes. I also have my opinions about Ray. Strictly
vibes based. But before but before we all lose our minds, we
just think for like a second. We do not know what the deal is
with her niece beyond what she said. We do not know what she
has done with the money except that she has said she's hired
a PI. She said she wants the rest to be for her niece to help
her live on her own, which has not happened yet. So, how would
people feel if they donated to Ray for her niece, but then she
used the money to keep a nice apartment because she broke up
with her boyfriend. That would be ridiculous. That money is for
her niece, right? If you want to critique her, you can ask. Asking
for money for her rent is unnecessary, and it is. So, just don't
donate. It is not some moral failing for her to make a GoFundMe.
She has an audience. If they want to give her money, so be it.
Besides, she already said she'll probably look for a second job
as well. Also says she sell cheek pics, just to be clear. The
last shrewd H3 fan. No, lots of these people are commenting on
on this stuff. Damn, she's rinsing the H3 family.
Okay, this is from the snark stuff. Okay, it's from the snarkers.
I don't know where this post where is this response written.
Is this in an Instagram post or something?
I just I don't know the source for the response. So, we've got
her response here to like the drama in general. I'm guessing
I would like to see more if we could if we could find like if
this is a Reddit thread, if this is Instagram or what. Riyle
just sent me a here. Let's watch Let's watch the real Riyle sent
of Mike Tomlin. Okay. Oh, wait. This is something else. This
is something. Wait, what the This real just doesn't work. Maybe
the Mike Tomlin thing just came up for me. This is just a random
broken link. Okay, never mind. Never mind. Never mind. Okay,
now that we've got all the context though, we can go back and
read a bunch of this stuff. might be agegated. Oh, maybe. Hold
on. What is that? Can you see that? My wand. Is that something?
Or maybe. Hold on. Ri said use this like anonymous viewer to
check the reel. Maybe that's what I need to do. My bad. My bad.
I wasn't watching correctly. Hold on. Hold on. Let me go pull
this up. I just assumed cuz it resolved that it was fine, but
it was not fine. Wait. Yeah, I'm giving you this link. What?
Okay. Oh, here we go. Oh, what day is this from? >> My
niece has been failed by CBS, her grandparents, and her parents.
CBS has sent her back to a home where a child and abuser.
I know they are those things because one of her parents, my sibling,
is the same that abused me beginning at age five. I refused to
let them take advantage of my silence anymore. I heard through
the family grapevine that she tried to take her own life a couple
months ago to try and escape. This lit a fire under me and since
then I've started to speak up and I have been seeing not just
results but fast results. tried for nearly a decade to get custody
of her. Resources like police and nonprofits that do wellness
checks can't help me because I don't have any solid information
on her whereabouts and they have hidden her from me so well.
The private investigator I have gotten thank
I feel like she really does believe this stuff to some extent.
Okay. And
there uh there's like an issue with that
[__] I don't know how to say this precisely. And
she her niece was her sister's daughter.
>> Her grandparents and her parents CBS has sent her back
to a home with a child an abuser.
I know they are those things because one of her parents, my sibling,
is the same that abused me beginning at age five.
Yeah, I you guys are like missing the idea that this could easily
be the sister that was her like abuser. I don't know why you
guys are acting like only men can do abuse. The [__]
we talking >> I refuse to let them take advantage of my
silence anymore. I heard through the family grape vine that she
tried to take her own life a couple months ago to try. >> Okay.
In any case, I could see this being like she believes this. It's
just she's telling you essentially that she has no way to verify
the things she's saying. that essentially she's she's laid it
all out that she heard that this niece maybe tried to take her
life and she filled in all of the gaps with stuff that she was
carrying from before which I don't think like it's I'm not saying
it's not true cuz I don't know but she doesn't know it right
she doesn't know it she's making it clear she doesn't know it
but she's still trying to call CPS CPS comes back and says no
she's fine that's not happening and again she could be correct
but what is she basing it on how do we how do we support this
>> try and escape. This lit a fire under me and since then
I've started to speak up and I have been seeing not just results
but fast results. I've tried for nearly a decade to get custody
of her. Resources like police and nonprofits that do wellness
checks can't help me cuz I don't have any solid information on
her whereabouts and they have hidden her from me so well. The
private investigator I have gotten thanks to early donations
is going to help me. So CPS and police will have to listen to
Okay, so now she says she has hired a private investigator
>> and take us seriously. Still need an attorney and the
ability to keep up with future attorney fees and to make sure
I have money. >> Oh, this is about getting up from 15,000
to something higher. Ability to keep future attorney or pay for
future attorneys fees is not good. Not what you want when that
time comes because I know from experience it can be so very
All I want is my niece in a place where she feels and is safe.
Whether that is with me or not, though I would prefer to have
her with me because I can guarantee her safety as well as time
to heal
>> Dude, something weird is going on with my microphone.
I'm like getting feedback from my microphone. I see it like jumping
up. Hold on a second. That's weird. Something weird going >> therapy,
college, whatever. Regardless, I know she doesn't want to be
there given she interacting with any of the posts helps a lot.
So, thank you very much. Thank you. Sure. I'm going to need over
$100,000,
>> Oh, boy. Oh,
>> We're already at 19,000. That's very
>> Yeah. Thank you. Thank you very much.
>> I dude
dude, what? very understandably. One of the ways that I was hoping
to help my niece has kind of fallen through for now. Um, which
is why I'm crying, but I kind of wanted to show that just because
like I'm trying to get people to understand this is real and
that she needs help now. >> Is going on with this microphone.
This is so weird. I'm getting some weird feedback from this.
Oh, she keeps she she just keeps showing pictures of the kid.
It's weird. It's not as bad as like the modern pictures that
are showing up. So, there is that. Sorry. I'm going to try to
figure out what's going on with this microphone at some point.
There's just like a weird There's some weird [__]
happening. Okay. Oh, now this is going to be way too quiet. [__]
Never mind. I'll turn it back up like this because I need it
this loud to actually go through. There we go. Here we go. Test
test test. Well, we'll figure we'll figure it out later.
This I tried testing this before. Somebody told me my audio was
kind of weird. I'm lost. What fell through?
Wait, hold on. Was she talking about the investigator falling
through before? Sorry. The There was some weird going on my audio
and like
>> My bad. My bad. I got I got occupied by the audio and
then I didn't listen at the end. >> Interacting with any
of the post helps a
>> So, thank you very much. Thank you. Sure. I'm going
to need over $100,000
though, but we're already at 19,000. So, that's very nice. Yeah.
Thank you. Thank you very much. So, very understandably, one
of the ways that I was hoping to help my niece has kind of fallen
through for now, which is why I'm crying, but I kind of wanted
to show that just
Oh, the thing that fell through is CPS. So, she called CPS. CPS
either couldn't find her or sent her back. But basically, what
I'm thinking is she has no information on the niece. She called
CPS somewhere, said, "Hey, there's a child in danger." She couldn't
give them any specific information on where the child was. So,
I'm guessing when she says later that CPS failed or CPS sent
her back into that situation, her niece that is, I'm guessing
she has no idea if CPS even contacted her niece
or anyone around that situation. Right. So, she called CPS. I
don't know if she even knows that CPS got in contact with the
parents or the kid cuz it sounds like she called CPS and was
like, "Well, my family's kind of around here. They they like
abused me and I think they're abusing my niece and I don't know
where they are." Like that is not a very credible report
to me or she's just making >> because like I'm trying to
get people to understand this is real and that she >> No,
don't don't just farm with the picture of the kid. Come on, man.
Come on, man.
Okay, so apparently she's got a response and it was in this same
Reddit thread, but it's just buried. So somehow massively downloaded.
I don't know if it's to this specific post. What is her [__]
called again? Her [__] is called
uh is it ra on on Reddit? What the [__] is it? The
original URLs to her replies. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you.
These are her two replies. Okay.
Boom.
boom one. And then boom two. Okay.
22 hours ago and then
one day ago. Okay.
A big thank you to everyone being sweet. I am so very appreciative
and it's very nice. Can I get my music going again? Jeez. Very
quiet. Okay. All right.
I genuinely uh y'all's kind words mean a ton and I genuinely
love y'all. Those being skeptical skeptical, I get some of you,
but I am looking for a second and third job. I put in a bunch
of applications today, including one for a hot dog for hot dog
on a stick and a bunch of thrift stores and a couple utility
clerk positions like what I was doing at Food for Less. I'm going
to be walking around my area soon in person to see who may be
hiring while continue to submit applications like the previously
mentioned ones on Indeed. I cannot stress enough that the money
for my niece is for my niece. 70k may seem like a lot, but that's
probably not even half of what I'd need to take this to court,
assuming she wants to press charges or get the emergency protective
action I need that could get her out of the situation before
she turns 18, plus giving me custody. The PIA cost 4,500 for
3 days surveillance. And since there's a solid chance she will
turn 18 before courts do anything cuz they're wicked slow, I
need to make sure I have money to get a security detail on top
of police escort to go pick her up. That this person's in like
a mental health crisis.
um like and there's a lot of things going on and realistically
I don't feel like
I feel like it would be unreasonable for people to not approach
this as if it's like a genuine like mental health crisis. I
like realistically it's like kind of funny when you think she's
grifting, but I don't I don't think that and I don't think she's
telling like a believable story. And I
like I would want this person her her boyfriend left. Her boyfriend
clearly knows about stuff. It's like whatever. You gotta go,
man. I I get that for you. But where's like does she have anybody
who could talk to her? Does she have anybody around? I just tuned
in, but where do we all where do we stand on the abuse claim?
I asked because I know how victims can often be predatory con
artists themselves and poison their own. Well, um I I have no
way to evaluate her personal abuse claims that she was abused
by her like parents andor people around her. I do know that people
who are abuse victims, yes, can end up becoming manipulative.
I know that people who are abuse victims can end up becoming
like sponges for abuse, as in they will try to escape situations
and they will put themselves in worse situations over and over
again. I understand that. Yeah. Seems like someone who started
on a lie and just kept digging the hole deeper and deeper, spinning
a tail. I don't know. Anyway, uh so she needs a police escort
to pick her up. Again, she doesn't even she hasn't spoken to
the niece in at minimum seven years. Eight years, it looks like
seven or eight years. Seven Seven years since 2019.
Okay. So, at minimum, she hasn't spoken to the niece in that
long. She doesn't know if the niece wants to be with her.
My sibling is dangerous. They are violent. My niece's GoFundMe
is not for me. And it would be so gross of me to use that money
for this when exactly as some of you said, it's not a necessity.
I could go back to the projects, which is the only place I'm
likely to end up because of debt from escaping the ex-husband
has wrecked my credit score. Wait. Because uh because of debt
from escaping the ex-husband has wrecked my credit score. What
actual long-term good would I be would I be doing for my niece
if I bring her to an area where she can't even sit in our home
comfortably? A place where I can't promise her physical safety
and therefore we're both constantly at least a little on edge.
Um this is to me justifying
um justifying using the niece monies for her own. That's a little
concerning in the not not like having a problem like like more
the you are maliciously trying to steal money from people place
where I can't promise for physical safety and therefore we're
both constantly at least a little on edge. That's not healing
from abuse. That's just more surviving. I wanted to be happy
and healthy. The rates for abuse victims getting abused more
because of a history of it is pretty high and I know from experience
it's very concentrated in areas that would accept me right now.
That is without getting crazy lucky or had time more time to
search.
this is justifying using some of that money for herself. Um,
100%.
And um, like honestly at this point she should be fully aware
that she is not the person her niece should go to. Like there
are other there literally anybody else. Literally just going
on her own would be better than like this is not her niece is
basically an adult.
This is probably the unpopular take right now. But I'm sorry
I don't believe everyone in her life is a lol. Both her parents
are abusers. Her sibling is her ex-husband is a I simply do not
believe everyone around this girl is evil.
That is
I.
So, I would imagine what's happened is this person
probably was abused by someone they
had the trust broken, and is very very um like suspicious of
a lot of other people and can easily be convinced that other
people are a lot more evil than they are, I would suspect. Okay.
Whenever someone says that uh that is an X, that's just why in
that exact phrasing, I know it's chat GPT. Wait, what are you
talking about here, Johnny? Evil Johnny Bravo. Oh yeah, hold
on.
Whatever. I don't know what you're talking about, actually. Like
when it's an aggressive analogy, that feels a little uncanny.
Oh, I see. I see. I see. That's not healing. That's That's what
you're talking about. That's not healing from abuse. That's just
more surviving.
Oh, you think this is chat GPT? Uhoh. We got M dashes in here,
actually. Oh, we got a lot of I'm seeing M dashes all over the
place. OH, M DASHES.
NO.
SO MANY M DASHES.
M dash is everywhere, dude. M dash. M dash. M dash.
They're all over. They're everywhere.
Oh god. This is absolutely Uhoh. There's an M dash with a hyphen.
Do you think she Do you think she did that? Oh, wait. Hold on.
What if this is um What if this is AI psychosis? What if she's
been talking? Cuz how do you even write an M dash on a standard
keyboard? I think you usually dash dash and a lot of things will
auto fix it. A lot of editors. Oh boy. Okay. I have never I have
never had stability until I made it here. And I will do anything
to maintain that. Examples. Swallowing pride and asking for help
if anyone's able and comfortable so I can keep this in the meantime
while I try to get the more uh the multiple more jobs to maintain
my home my my home on my own. While I spend this year healing
and hopefully finally getting Francis, I will be looking for
trailer homes cuz they're actually really nice inside and very
cheap. They just don't gain value when you sell it later on.
But who cares if I have a good home for Francis and I. It's super
hot fire that some of y'all are also autistic but can function
better than I can. I'm jealous of you. Lol. But you you are being
able to do something doesn't mean I can. Especially with a disability
like autism that is so very
>> Uhhuh. Dude, what?
Dude, what?
That being said, I can do this now that I've been on Prozac for
a year, for over a year, and that's going well, but it is still
going to result in panic attacks intense enough to shorten my
lifespan a good bit. I want to make it to 113. So, yeah,
obviously donate to places like PCRF, rain, places to help the
Congo and Sudan. Donate to help my niece escape her abuse if
you would like and can. And then after that, if you want to,
I am accepting the help. Yeah. and would love to return the favor
when I am able to for other people besides just my niece though
she is my top priority. Donate to Sudan
and Congo. Damn. But no Gaza. No, there's terrorists there. It's
terrorists. Terrorists and snarkers in Gaza. Okay, we couldn't
donate there. My ex My now ex is a good egg. Be nice civil to
him, please. And thank you. Humans are complex. Brains are a
lot. And he has his own stuff going on. He and his family are
helping as well. Still to make sure I can stay safe. It was simply
not meant to be. you know, and I don't want to just survive.
I want to be happy. I've had a proper taste of happy the last
few years for the first time ever, and I'll be damned if I let
that go without a fight. Donate, don't donate, though, if you
don't want to, obviously. Anywh who, I got to go cry some more.
Again, thank you for all the sweet words to the people who left
them. And thank you so much for your help.
Not answer to any of the people saying anything about, "Hey,
we think this is fake." Hold on. What is the parent to this?
The parent to this was, "Hi, Ray. Where's the receipts then?
Hold on.
This is to her thing which she posted. Okay, so then it's Hi,
Ray. Where are the receipts then?
Why haven't you set up a trust in her name if that was the intent?
Where are the receipts from the PI, the lawyer? Why did you fundra
to save a child who's going to be an adult in less than 6 months
using pictures of when she was less than 6 years old? It does
not cost 140K to accomplish your goals. Anyone who's worked with
a lawyer would understand that. just admit you've misappropriated
the funds unless you can show the receipts or a trust in her
name in that exact value that's been donated to you under her
name. 18 is legally an adult, but that's still a child. She still
needs help. I'm not just going to abandon her. The trust will
happen when everything else gets paid for. when everything else
gets paid for so I can make sure I can cover all that. Cuz if
I ran out of money for lawyers, which I don't have yet, because
it's not easy to find a good lawyer that won't try to take advantage
of the situation given how little time there is, then I could
easily get forced into the same position as many other victims
in court, which is being forced to close it one way or another
instead of helping her get the justice she deserves and hopefully
getting those freaks in prison where they belong. You do not
pay to prosecute somebody through the criminal justice system.
That's not your lawyers who pay to do that. Okay?
This is just wrong. If I can get an emergency protective action,
which is some legal thing I don't understand fully yet because
I'm not a lawyer, but my PI recommended this, then I can get
her out before she turns 18 and hopefully get custody of her,
even with the short deadline. For that, I need a PI to keep hustling
though until I can get solid proof to make the emergency protective
action even possible. I've said, "Oh, no way." This guy was like,
"Hey, there's legal action you could take, but I'd need at least
like a hundred more hours on this. You'd have to give me a lot
more money for you to get that." Okay, we need we need way more
money here. I've said many a time that I have no problem posting
receipts and stuff as I can, but right now I can't do that solidly
without doxing my PI. The other stuff I don't even I don't have
yet. As mentioned, it's beyond unfortunate, but these things
take time unless you really have some hard evidence of the crimes
that have gone on. It's one of the hardest things to prove in
court. I don't have recent pictures of her because she's being
isolated by the abusers. So, I use the pictures I do have in
hopes someone who knows her IRL, like a friend or a teacher,
could let her know that I'm fighting for her so she can hopefully
hold out easier and I can help her escape easier by planning
with her instead of showing up out of the blue. Bro, is she actually
going to go kidnap this girl? Like, this is this is a problem.
I'm sorry. It's actually a problem. This is pretty rough. This
is pretty tough, man. [__] is going on over here?
It's also that people take it more seriously because there's
a level of separation when you don't have to look the victim
in the eye. Oh, hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Yeah, I know that
that is the next line. Okay. You are incredibly demanding. Lol.
Sorry to be blunt about it, but you're also kind of being a butt
right now. So, you know, skepticism is valid, but your comment
just read as illinformed. That sounds like chat GPT to me. That
sounds like AI for sure, but whatever. Uh, you're incredibly
demanding, lol. Sorry to be blunt about it, but you're also kind
of being a butt right now. So, you know, skepticis skepticism
is valid, but your comment just read is completely illinformed.
I'm sorry, but what? How is he demanding exactly? 70K is more
money than I what I earn pre-tax working for a full year in a
highly physical job. And I'm sure that applies to the vast majority
of people in this thread. Not to mention that saving 70k would
take closer to a half decade or more. And he is being demanding.
How is it more demanding to provide proof? I am sure some uh
I'm sure between you and a PI you guys can figure it out than
to work a 9 to5 and saving zero money saving money for a decade.
So yeah, the community dumped 70k plus to you pretty much literally
overnight with next to zero work required. It isn't much to ask
for some proof.
It is not.
It is not. Oh my god, I never thought about it that way. The
fact that I have earned half of that in one year from work. Where
the is the money gone? Genuinely, this is disgusting. Wow, dude.
Money is hard to come by. Money is rough. All right, speaking
of guys, we've got about 7 minutes left on the stream. We have
made
She should rebrand to Lauo. BB Poison. What is wrong with you?
What is actually you are a sick human being. What what is your
what is your major malfunction son is your problem. It's very
close
Okay,
dude. Stop. Stop. Stop. Oh, I saw this from the the enforcer
up here that one of the cities in Iran has flipped. Guy declared
independence.
So he's an independent governor over there. They're not wrong.
They're not wrong. They're just an kind of like Asmin Gold.
Not wrong. just kind of a prick, man. Oh, hold on. I forgot there's
a Caseyron reaction to the Asmin Gold comments. This is the Dioro.
Okay, hold on. We'll pull this up. I'll try to keep this >> and
I will be talking about Idubbbz. I promise. I promise. I promise
I will. I
>> Okay. Okay. >> Oh, I got really clicketity clackety
sound right now.
I don't know how I'm going to fix this.
How will I ever >> All right, cool. Okay, now this crazy.
This is absolutely unreal. I've had about 10 minutes to glance
this over. This is what I was doing. I I had 20 minutes to set
up a stream. 10 minutes was spent looking at what the [__]
this is. So, my understanding is Thank you. >> You claim
to care about and you're hyping up a dude who has a segment on
a show called Ultimate Review. >> Thank you, >> Cherry.
No, Cherry, please. The money has all gone. >> This guy
makes insane money, by the way. like always just insane money.
>> Raphael is a >> the hot sauce collab. Oh, is he
doing um is he doing hot sauce with Billy Mitchell? That's what's
going on. >> He's a moderator of the H3H3 subreddit and
the recipient of multiple GoFundMes
So, I saw this post right here saying, "Show her some love, guys."
And I'm looking at this and I'm just like, "What the am I reading?
I'm single again. I just like bought him a customcleared Nintendo
DS and Pokemon Emerald for Christmas because he mentioned one
in the latter over two years ago and it's not going to be here
till Valentine's Day. Lmo when we were supposed to go on a family
trip with his family. No hate to Ben.
Okay, dude. Ben is getting obliterated right now. I didn't even
realize that when I was looking at this the first time. She just
name drops this guy who I guess dumped her. He's a good egg.
It's going to be what it's going to be. I'll have a Nintendo
and a Pokemon Emerald soon. That's cool. So this is like weird.
This is just venting. Yeah, sure.
2026 is off to a start, bro. >> Oh, do you think do you
think his chat's going to start defending this person
for houses to be in an area that would make him happier? Like
this is like a I'm sorry. Even if you're just venting on your
social media,
I this is crazy to just be like divulging this amount of information.
I asked him the night before if this if he wanted to marry me
like we've been asking each other. Maybe this is just ah okay,
keep going. I'm so for real right now. It might be Only Fans
time. I'm scared to leave my home and I need to resign my lease
in about a week. My rent is more than what I make on my own.
So, you see where this is going. Sell cheek pics to get quick
money and keep my place and get a second job. Not ideal, but
I don't want to feel like I'm in a horror movie again. And I
feel so safe here. I can I I can see myself being safe here.
All right. So, the rap male person is like, "Hey, here's all
this personal information about me. I got into a I got in a breakup.
I'm going to be forced to show pictures of myself online to make
some money." And then it got posted to the H3H3 subreddit because,
hey, this is a moderator that supports this community. So, like
maybe they should throw some support back, right? That's this
is we're doing this the way that
uh Oh, does he not know about this yet? Wait, he knows about
all the other stuff, right? He said he's looking over it. He's
got to know a little bit about all the other shell. >> I
learned about it. Okay, like this is how I learned about it.
This is the order of events that I learned about it.
Emerald is like $400 now. He blew it. That is true. Emerald is
the best Pokémon game. This feels like a quick path to long-term
debt. Taking on rent you have no sustainable means to pay for.
True. Would strongly encourage her to take the GoFundMe money
and put it towards some moving fees uh to be safe and more manageable.
Monthly rent. >> That's the Oreo commentator of the year.
The best commentator of the year. I had to explain to my 40-year-old
supervisor at work. What >> is that? Is that
I recognize that voice. I listen to that stream a little bit.
That's a That's a stream where Gokanaro was just brutally on
Nicholas Yorio for being a for like the entire stream and Nick
grabbed that little tidbit out of there and threw it up. You
manageable monthly rant
of the year. The best commentator of the year. I >> Yeah,
that's Gokaro 100% just
No, no, no, no, no, hold on. It's him going like Nicholas saying
something incredibly obvious and then laughing and like like
trying to act like he's explaining something incredibly obvious
and Gokaro goes, "Oh, like water is wet." Thank you, Nicholas
Yoro. Nicholas Yoro, commentator of the year 2025. It's him on
him repeatedly.
That's that's what the actual context is there. I had to explain
to my 40-year-old supervisor at work what meant. He now says
it unironically and I'm waiting for it to land him an hour.
Uh doesn't force her to rely on others. Uh do things like only
fan she doesn't want to do. She seems super talented as an artist.
Perhaps we'll find uh she'll find a way to lean into that as
well. I feel the same way trying to live in South California
on a single person's income. I assume they rented it together
knowing they could afford it on combined income but not solo
which is what most couples do, right? But she's trying to resign
it solo, which makes no sense. True. And I keep reading down
the way people resort to Only Fans like this is so sad.
And sometimes it's written that way on purp. I don't know. Um,
why is she talking about her neighbors in the >> Wait,
what? Oh, he's uh
I don't know. >> He's already against this woman, this
stupid. Okay. Nicholas Yorio knows one thing if nothing else.
Okay. You want to come out against the big girl who who uses
her body to like get approval online? You're going to win every
single time. Nicholas Nicholas knows that immediately. He's just
like, "Oh, I'll I'll bet I'll bet on the other side every time."
>> I don't know. Um, why is she talking about her neighbors
and the projects eating cats to raise Wait, what? Funds for herself?
Wait, what?
Wait, what? >> Wait, why was she talking about that? He
isn't Wait, did he >> eating cats? >> Oh, is he unaware
of the GoFundMe, too? >> I missed the cats part. >> she's
talking about eating cats. So, this is the This is where it really
pops off. This is where it pops off. Oh, he just read somebody
else's example of the GoFundMe.
Dude, no, nobody's going to point out that her saying she was
a 100 times before she was seven is clearly the most insane thing
said. I got to see. We'll know if Nicholas has any chance to
to make it back into the light. Okay. Depending on how he reacts
to that comment. I was a hundred times before I was seven. Yeah.
Okay. Okay. If Nicholas goes, "Well, I don't want to make fun
of that. I wouldn't want to offend the wine moms. We'll know.
We'll know. Okay. If he's totally audience captured or if he
has to like pop off about it.
>> Oh, so
okay. Only one thing we can do nudes immediately. I was going
to make a separate post about this, but it seems like a good
place. Ry has gotten plenty of love from the community already
in the amount of $70,000.
She started a GoFundMe on the pretense of saving her niece, who
will be an adult in April, from an apparently abusive situation.
This niece will be a legal adult in April. No updates have been
provided regarding retaining a lawyer or a private investigator,
let alone setting up a trust in Okay, what the [__]
is happening? What? At this point, I was like, yo, what the is
happening? So, I did some research.
I'm not going to show the person's name. Actually, I am going
to show the I am going to show the person's face. You know what?
I'm going to show this person's face. This is like an insanely
manipulative photo to pick for a for a 17-year-old girl. To be
clear, this is like an insanely manipul Are they all like this?
Oh my god. Okay. Yeah, they are. Okay. Yeah, that's like that
is an insanely manipulative photo to pick for a 17. >> I
do find it a little weird.
>> But in the opposite direction, you're like um Okay.
I just didn't think >> Just to be clear, >> my niece
has been >> Why is Why is she showing the face? She shouldn't
be showing the face. Nick probably shouldn't be showing the face
if he did any pre-work. I'm not going to hit him up too I'm not
going to like hit him too hard on that because I showed a little
bit of it. >> Failed by CP. >> It It's very weird
that he was like, "I'm not showing the face." Wait, no, I am
showing the face. I guess it's of a 5-year-old. Like that one's
probably less bad. I do think the ones of her now that you could
tie to her now are explicitly like quite bad to show. Um I get
that it's like weird to have the 5-year-old's picture in there,
but I don't I'm not saying that's like I don't think that's evil.
I think on on his part to show it, it drives home the point.
I think I wouldn't do it. >> Her grandparents and parents
CPS has sent her back home to a child and abuser. I know there
are these things cuz they're my uh cuz one of her parents, my
sibling is the same, right? But okay, this is another horrible
thing. I I didn't need to know that like your sister got assaulted
either. I don't know if like I your niece, sorry, your niece
got assaulted.
That's like crazy to just divulge that information without their
knowledge. That's like insane. Yeah, that's like I I think that's
like absolutely horrible.
>> Oh, just wait until he gets to the part where he figures
out that this person doesn't even know that yet. I don't believe
she's ever been told that this >> My parents, her grandparents
are physically and mentally abusive as well and support.
>> Whoa. Oh, Stickers. What's up, Dickers? People rapist.
>> God, that alert is really loud. But thank you for the
raid. We're we're watching the Nicholas Dioro reaction to the
scamming H3 mod. Okay. >> Child to the point of accusing
me and of false memories as well, later admitting to it happening,
but saying that she we should get over it. I refuse to let them
take advantage of my silence anymore. I've tried for years to
get custody of her, but my parents found out. They contacted
my sibling and they have hidden her from me since then.
Okay, so now it says she is now 17, turning 18 in April of 2026.
This GoFundMe was started
in October 27th, 2025.
Raf Raphael
20 hours ago
says, um, things take time. >> Where is it? >> Things
take time. These things take time. You're being >> trust
will happen when everything else gets paid. So, I can cover that
if we get our money for lawyers. She doesn't have lawyers yet.
Raphael does not have lawyers yet. We're in January. Okay. We're
halfway to the point where she's 18 and can leave on her own
accord. So, we're going to contact lawyers to take a child out
of the house 3 months before they leave on their own when you're
not in contact with this person and have no idea what's happening
over there. What the is going on here? This is crazy. You have
no contact with this person. Presumably, they don't even know
if you've raised this money, right? This this GoFundMe started
at $5,000. It's up to it's it's up to 62,000. And the goal to
get on the video is happening here. This is crazy.
>> Wow. might cost a lot because I've Googled how much
lawsuits cost. Okay. Yeah. I mean, I hate to be the I hate to
be an I do have hope. Someone >> reading comments. Come
on, man. >> I feel like we have the best. And there's plenty.
>> Oh, this is her. Okay. Yes. This is her gofund me. Let's
[__] go. >> Thousand dollars raised so far.
What the >> Let's go.
>> Read the line. Read the line. Wait, did he already read
the line? >> Yeah. I just got >> Oh, he he read the
line already. Hold >> The carnage
fans to make rent. Oh, boy. Give me this. I want to make sure
my
thing doesn't Okay, so this is her.
$3,000 raised so far. What the Okay. >> Wait. Is he not
reading the line? No, this is where we were. >> Yeah. On
the I got flashbanged by that. Dude, I'm not playing the intro.
I'm not playing the intro.
>> He read it. >> He read it. >> I'm not playing
the intro. >> Play the intro, Nick. Play the play the >> We're
just gonna move past that stuff. Let's get the content.
I told you. I told you. I told you, dude. I'm sorry. It's so
over. It's never been more over. It's never been more over than
it is right now.
Okay, somebody link me. Anybody got the ultimate review intro?
Because we need to look at how this guy's entire commentary career
is at this point. Not technically. He's making more money than
he ever has. He is financially secure. He has made every correct
financial decision. But I'm going to say he's right because he
will not laugh at this incredibly funny statement cuz that's
up. Okay.
What? That's so up that he won't play this. He won't play the
intro.
He wouldn't play. Dude, that's crazy. But I didn't I his new
audience, they just will not like that, right? They wouldn't
like that. That would be very bad for him to do. >> A while
after that, I met who would be my partner for the next two years
until yesterday. Meeting him made me go from feeling like a horror
thriller to romantic comedy most of the time. We had kids names
picked out and talked about all the time. Okay, dude. That's
crazy that you have to address.
>> You have to listen to this right now about 30 seconds.
>> What? What is this? >> Okay. All right. We're
back. All right. >> Many have come to believe that this
is a segment in which Nick reviews videos of women crying over
being assaulted. I too also actually believed that uh because
Hassan [__] said it and I used to really like Hassan
[__] However, after watching some of Nicholas Dioro's
VODs over the past few months, I recognized that Ultimate Rick
review is a satirical name and the segment highlights how YouTube
drama consistently turns other people's trauma into content.
There is some weird thing that happens in the political space
when people are on the back foot in a conversation. They need
to just start retreading every dead family member in their entire
life to justify their actions. I I This is not a
Wow.
Hassan told me root review is bad, but I've come to learn that
root review is really about a dispassionate
yet still compassionate analysis
of how people people's trauma is used on the internet as currency.
Wow. Thank you, Nicholas, for
truly understanding what all of these H3 audience members really
needed. Okay.
Literally lying that review is compassionate. Well, yeah. It's
like, I'm sorry. It's literally it's mocking you if you do a
bad job. Okay. There have definitely been rap reviews where he's
basically laughing at somebody who's, you know, exaggerating
their trauma. All right. That's definitely happened. Address
your breakup in a GoFundMe. He comes from money that he and especially
his parents have worked very hard for when we moved out here
to LA in Janu. All right, then you have to leave the coastal
city. You have to go somewhere you can afford.
Uh we were a What is this $3,000 going to get you a month's rent?
You get to stay in your house for another month. Like I don't
What are we doing here? What is happening?
Like to give this person any money, I would need to not know
any of this context and hear her talk about how I need one month's
more rent to find a location with lower rent and move out of
the state. and I need time to transport my goods and services.
Then it's like, all right, yeah, sure, whatever. That's the stuff
that I need to hear before I consider giving any goods and services
>> in this case. >> Like, I need like a a set plan
of how to get out of LA. That needs to be like number one. Point
numero uno. We were able to get a supremely beautiful place,
such a safe and goated area. A gated area. Goed, dude. The goat.
Thank you for the $5, my man. Uh, one that I could have never
dreamed of living in. And I can't drive, but there's also a lot
of stuff to walk around to here. all the essentials like a >> dude.
You actually need that first part to really call out just like
how
bad this stuff is. >> Grocery store. Wow. >> There's
so many lies in that first part where it's like, yeah, her her
husband was a as well. I've been here for a year now. I have
a couple friends within walking distance. So, I feel very confident
I would be happy staying here even on my own. Well, why don't
you ask them to let you move in with them for the time being
so you can get back on your feet? I cannot afford this place
on my own at the moment and I need to resign my lease within
about a week of writing this. I don't have good credit as one
could probably guess from the generational poverty and not having
any guidance. I'm trying so hard to do better specifically for
my niece who is stuck in an abusive situation who's being ignored
and neglected by CPS and police. I have another GoFundMe posted
for her so I can help her press charges. So, uh, should she want
to and give her a stable place she can live with me while I guess
we both heal
>> the niece she hasn't seen since they were 6 years old.
Uh, the GoFundMe continues to pay for the >> That's not
true, but that's probably hard to get context. >> Take
care of that. >> So, that's where this money is going.
Uh, every donation is appreciated. I don't want to go back to
the horror movie feeling.
My plan would be to use this GoFundMe money to keep my apartment
while I look for a second local job. Nah, you need to leave Los
Angeles. You cannot afford to stay in Los Angeles. You have to
go away from Los Angeles.
Is this is like the MOST EXPENSIVE PLACE IN THE COUNTRY.
>> You have found the one place more expensive than New
York.
>> You need to go somewhere that you can >> How long
until he gets to some of the other Instagram reels and [__]
>> Bad news.
Um, so this is the post. My niece has been failed by CPS, her
grandparents, and her parents. So, this is the Ray post that
got 92,000 likes on IG. She's trying to gain custody of her niece
who's in a dangerous situation. This is an early post about it.
All the love to Ray and her niece. Can we get a GoFundMe link?
>> No comments. >> Family. Family. So, they're out
here definitely ready to support, which I mean, good nature,
maybe not good outcome. We'll see. Listen, I know I said the
Reddit, um, I am old. I am 32 years old. It's okay. Hey, I'm
32 and watch the YouTubers all the time. Hopefully the family
and Ethan can get this all funded. >> Oh my god, she's
9% of her goal. Who is this? Community manager, long time. >> A
lot of other content here he could have gotten to a mess, dude.
This is a total mess. You got to be careful
and that's that's being nice. Ray raised her goal 13 separate
times and now it's at 70k. Well, I mean, if it hits 70k, are
we sure it's not going to go up to like 80, 90? And it seems
like she's >> she's justified 100. And then I think was
the last one 150? I believe she said in a response post that
it's probably going to cost her at least double what she'd earned
already, right? I think it was somewhere around 150. >> Best
nicest possible read of this situation where I don't act like
this is a total,
you know, like if I'm ignoring the fact that my brain tells me
this could be a scam. The nicest thing is that this PI has been
just taking you guys for a ride for like six like well not six
months but like three months now. Like since October 27th >> of
the year the best commentator of the >> She's giving us
an estimate here. >> 2,000 Canadian dollars. >> my
brother needs pinball. I mean rent.
>> Um no he's not. He's saying it's a scam. He's saying
that like my initial judgment is it's a scam.
I'm sorry if you guys aren't reading between the lines. He's
trying to say it without saying it directly. It's like probably
so he doesn't get clipped.
But he is he is saying it's my read that it's a scam. But if
I wanted to be really nice, which I have no reason to be, then
maybe you're just getting taken for a ride. >> [__]
taking you guys for a ride for like six like Well, not six months,
but like 3 months now. Like since October
>> of the year, the best commentator of the >> She's
giving us an estimate here. >> 2,000 Canadian dollars.
No, >> my brother needs pinball. I mean rent. I mean private
investigator funds. It sounds to me because they said what was
it like how much money were the estimates here? The PI cost how
much? That was in this thread, right? Yeah. In this one, she
said she gave an estimate.
for 3 days of surveillance.
I mean, that's not going to [__] last very long.
Like, oh, I don't want to talk to a lawyer cuz they'll take me
for a ride. Who told you that? The personal investigator that
you're paying like [__] $5,000 every three days to.
>> That is what I said. >> Crazy. from 4.5 to 70K.
Yeah, but dude, like significant point part uh portions of this
are gone if she has a private investigator there for 3 weeks.
If you're using $4,500 to get this PI to do this for 3 days,
>> when did when did she say she'd done 3 days of stuff
that was fairly recent. >> You have to kind of flip the
dice and hope literally hope that somebody gets abused in front
of them. >> That is true. I thought the PI was basically
to find the woman, not to
Obviously, the PI is not observing until they see it occur,
right? That's like that that can't possibly be the conditions.
You don't know where she is. You hired the PI to find the person.
Your story is like not internally
>> The re like to get a personal investigator, you need
to spend more than 3 days to find evidence of something like
this. So, it sounds like this personal investigator is like just
>> private investigator priv private
>> off of H3H3.
Nicholas Dioro dreamed about this last night and after watching
Nick's stream, I'm kind of blackpilled on this.
>> They just earned another goal. Yeah, dude. They need
to raise the goal. Flip the dice. It's private investigator.
Yeah, I know. I know what a PI is. Thank you. This feels like
a SK.
>> Well, far be it for me to tell you what you know or
don't know. Far be it for >> Yeah, it does. It does. Does
the niece know there's a PI following her and her family? No.
No, she has no idea. She hasn't seen this person in like 10 years.
Goofy.
Well, there's no evidence the niece even There's also no evidence
the niece wants to leave. Yeah. Doesn't she literally have to
find the niece first, let alone Yeah, that's what the PI has
been doing on Twitter. >> I mean, private invest Oh, did
I >> Jesus private investigator? Thank you. She's going
to be a fallen fan before. >> Oh, he admits he's wrong.
Okay. I Dude, I thought he would go into the like the actual
Instagram and whatever. Make some more commentary, but apparently
not. That's dude,
has he ever been when has he ever shied away from mocking people
like this? That's just bizarre to me. Anybody who's like a part
of the old commentary audience have to look at this and just
go, "Oh, this is like not the same. This guy changed entirely."
Also, wasn't this guy just saying Wait, hold on.
Do I need to go get his logs from when he was talking about the
video? Wait, I think Quimman ran a segment on this today. Let
me message him real quick. That scream is Discord. Whoops. Hold
on. Oh, hold on. Hold on. Unpause the end of March.
>> What do you mean unpause?
Of course she does. She's right here. >> Yeah. Yeah, I
know. That's why I didn't want to unpause cuz I had scanned forward
and seen that he goes back to just looking at this kid's picture
for some reason.
>> Hit play from somewhere in the middle. >> Oh my
god, she's at 89. It's not a grooming situation.
At least not this part of the discussion. All right, we're talking
about custody. 18 is literally an adult. Dreamed about this last
night and after watching Nick's stream, I'm kind of blank. >> We
should raise THE VOTING AGE. NO, >> NO. STOP HITTING ALL
THE THE ACQUIRED TALKING POINTS. STOP IT. STOP IT. STOP IT. IT
DOESN'T WORK IN THIS CONVERSATION.
You can't do the brain thing in this conversation. We're talking
about legality. YOU CAN'T DO THAT. NO, YOU CAN'T MENTION THE
PREFRONTAL CORTEX. THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THIS. Oh god,
where is the money Skyler? I get so frustrated. You mentioned
18-year-old and there's like 50 people,
dude. Okay, hold on. Hold on. There's some There's some Nick
commentary that I do want to go into here.
Just wait. I don't want to listen to this yap the whole time.
Let me let me scroll up. I saw these get pasted at Queen's Discord.
Let me see if they're still here somewhere. The Here's the hot
Making a hot sauce with Billy Mitchell. Wow. Wow. So cool. The
hab the Nicholas the Oreo habanero sauce. $60 for three bottles.
Amazing. Amazing.
Stunning. Brave. Very very cool.
Okay. So, this is Nick responding to the what is it? The um the
junk drawer gaming video. Okay.
Let me see if these are in order.
So, I can walk through each of the issues as we come about them.
All right. Briefly mentioned the death and the first day. So,
he's talking about the the snarker. Okay. The whole snarker
All right. I asked Qua, but I dude, I didn't watch the segment.
I was even going to talk about this, but now that we're talking
about Nick, we might as well talk about it. Okay. So, he goes
to his Discord to respond to critics. Now, instead of ever addressing
anything on stream, he just responds in his Discord. Okay. I
briefly mentioned the death in the first day and said Dan said
to Dan Saltman that Ethan misreported it as well as the following
stream. I'm pretty sure I mentioned it more as an example of
when I disagreed with Ethan. Is that true? Can we get a citation
on that? Do we have citations on that? So that's him talking
about the fox lady. Okay. The the fox sanctuary lady that got
snarked to death that he said that Ethan said got snarred to
death and then Nicholas apparently said, "No, no, no. That's
not true. That's not true." Oh, dude. This is already out of
order. What the Sorry. This was the first message I watched like
the first four minutes of that video. His first argument was
how I never condemned Ethan for making that snarkitor's death
about himself. which follows up with, I briefly mentioned the
death the first day and said to Dan Sullivan that Ethan misreported
it as well the following stream. I'm pretty sure I mentioned
it more as an example of when I disagreed with Ethan since 9:34
is the next one, I think. Let me just make sure this all right.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Um,
like this clip is literally me condemning a Hassan action and
using Ethan as an example of a time when he did the same.
Okay. I'll have to go find it in the uh in the Junk Draw Gaming
video or something or go find his stream with Dan as well. Dan
didn't use this arc Redditor thing. Well, I'm trying to I'm trying
to see where he argued with Dan about it because he said he did
it. But is there an example of where he did it? I will say you're
never beating the post H3 show allegations, lol. But I feel a
lot that levy that against you think it's because you don't want
to stomp on their stream when in reality because of EHD, it's
better to start after they're done so you can catch stuff. Oh,
this is what I wanted. This is the piece I wanted here. Okay,
is these next two logs. All right, these are like the big ones
that I'm kind of laughing about.
So, this person, this person's basically saying like EHD, Ethan
Hassan, Destiny. It's like the content he does all the time.
Is basically he does like H3 content all the time. Okay. Or antihassan
content. I mean, if I quit my job and start streaming directly
over them, I will. Lol. As in he will be stomping on their stream
or something. I'm selfish. I only want you to start soon so I
can watch live. Yuriel responds, "If the criticism is topics,
then sure, but if it's a stream time thing, Google 8 hour work
days. Lol. Lol." Oh, this is the one. This is the big one right
here. This is what it's all about. Okay, this is the big one.
I would love to start my streams at 4 or sooner every day and
actually fall asleep at nighttime. If I wanted to leech hard
off of Ethan's audience, I would be a morning stream and farm
money before they spend it all on Ethan. I would probably do
better in that slot running against Chud.
Yeah. Okay, bro. Okay, dude.
This just seems a little goofy where he's like, "This is him
again just acting like he he built he this is him following."
There's a follow-up in the previous comment where he talked about
how like he basically propped up and built up Chud's channel
for him, right? Like I think he basically intimated that directly
and now this is just a further continuence. Oh, I could I could
kill this guy. Yeah, I could kill this guy if I wanted to. I
I should just run against Chud. I'd do even better.
What?
Why do you think that? He saved Chud's career and could end it
whenever he wants apparently. Dude, I I just seem so weird for
him to be saying these things cuz I think he still says he's
like friends with Chud for whatever reason, right? Like he consistently
says, "Well, I'm friends with Chud still. I'm friends with I'm
friends with Chud still. I'm friends with Chud still." I'm just
yinking this from Queen's Discord. I have no idea what this is.
Hold on. What is this? What is this? What is this? Look, I'm
not going to say that Ethan hasn't done stuff like this. Ethan
absolutely has like jumped in and and and kind of um I guess
I guess like interjected his own situation into like clips that
pop up. I just find this so shameless. The DHS security shot
her puppy and wrote about in a book cops kill 10,000 dogs a year.
A decent number of people who support all this think I abuse
my go.
I think the one that like if we're going to make a critique towards
Ethan, the one that sticks in the back of my mind. >> Yeah,
I realized it's this Fox lady, it was in their mind, I think
we covered it briefly, was there was a clip that came out. What
was it? Someone killed themselves on on Reddit or something.
Uh like a Redditor killed themselves and they were blaming like
a snark subreddit that did it. But then a couple hours later
once people did research there were like hardly any posts in
this subreddit. All the posts were like low up votes or whatever.
like nobody actually like interacted with the snark community
and it realistically didn't have anything to do with or it didn't
play a large role in what happened to that person like the snark
community was extremely small um and then it kind of got pushed
into like this is the danger of snark communities or whatever.
I think like maybe waiting to kind of see how things turn out
before jumping on that would benefit everybody. I think I disagreed
with Dan on that, right? Dan Salman posted it as well and I think
Ethan posted it to his story. It was a lady from SA Fox.
>> Oh, maybe maybe. Did Wait, where did he disagree?
Do you ever disagree directly with them? Be interesting. Somebody
posted this as well talking about how much money he's making.
What is this site? Yeah, that complet that number is completely
fake, which is hilarious because I just assumed it was real.
I did not make anywhere close to that in Super Chat revenue.
I do more than good enough though. I don't really want to expand
on my finances. None of these calculations consider ad revenue.
Um, is he talking about Playboard? Playboard is like almost 100%
accurate on super chats. The place where it's not accurate is
yeah, it doesn't consider ad revenue, which is a lot more money.
And then it doesn't consider memberships, which is a lot more
money again.
So, if anything, it's obviously would be like underplaying Nick's
revenue. So, this is from December 18th. I don't think this is
from Junk Drawer. Why is he talking about ad revenue? Cuz he
makes way more. He doesn't want to expand on his finances cuz
he knows he's making a if he's talking about Playboard, Playboard
is like totally accurate, but I don't know what site he's talking
about here. I'm just pulling these logs again from Queen's Discord
with no context.
I just decided to pull them because I was like interested in
getting a little more here. Getting like a little bit more of
this going. All right. Oh, someone care to explain what Discount
Lyrics is talking about. Dario's Discord meltdown. Discord meltdown.
Okay, that seems like some fun. LMAO, where was the meltdown?
I legit don't know, but I can't wait for someone else to watch
and report back. What exactly is you referring to? Don't tell
me. It's when me, Duncas, and Noid were talking earlier. Did
my Discord melt down or did I melt down? Slow news day clearly.
I think I think Queen is just going to keep talking about this
guy forever until he does something about it. It's from Alex
Novel. Oh, did Alex Novel do a video on Dioro or did he talk
about it? Like how much money Dioro is making? Wait, if it's
from an Alex Novel video, we could just find that. Let me see.
Let me see. Alex Novel
>> Now look at this vile. >> We never watched this
video. I don't think this. Yeah, this would be from this video.
Hold on. Let me see if we find Dioro here. >> Dioro. Oh,
it's not from that. I don't see him getting mentioned in Alex
Novel's video at all. Yeah, I don't see it at all.
Screenshot in his video that used Queenman's thumbnail. Hold
on. Let me see it. Let me see it. Let me see it. Let me see it.
Maybe it's in a different Maybe it's in a different video. >> Now
look at this.
>> Oh, it's definitely in this one, isn't it? Whoops. It's
in this one. My bad. Hold on. Nick, >> I call him Jolly
Saint Nick.
>> I love Nicholas Dioro. I'll say it. >> I've been
watching your content. I think you're very I think you're a very
funny >> And and I I feel
>> it is Playboard then. It is Playboard.
No, that's accurate. Why is Nick just lying about whether Dude,
we watch We watch your stream. We see how much you get super
chatted all the time. You don't get, by the way, there's like
what 65% taken off of that. Sorry, 30% taken off of that or something
by YouTube. 30 or 35%. So, he doesn't make that money directly,
but he makes more than that money. Like, he's obviously making
a total
I I don't know why he'd even lie about that. That's very bizarre
to me.
Okay, got it. All right, that's what that was referencing. I
guess we're we're done with all that. We're done with all that.
We're done with all that. I do think it's Yeah, it's weird that
he just say this site is inaccurate when the site is like demonstrably
accurate. Very strange. If Nick wants to show that it's not accurate,
then just show your super chat revenue for like a stream that
corresponds to the website and show how it's like way off. That's
all you got to do. I mean, or or he's saying that I don't get
that much money, which is true cuz YouTube takes a split, but
you're not going to give anything away about your income if you
just show for one stream where it's inaccurate. Okay.